[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
game eight of the World Chess
Championship was another swing and miss
as nerve seems to have taken over this
tension-filled match Viviano Caruana got
the sharp opening he wanted against
world champion Magnus Carlsen but
nervous hesitation on the part of the
Challenger allow the champ back in the
saddle and the game followed the
previous seven by ending in a draw the
players are back to do battle with the
eyes of the world watching their every
move game 9 live from London coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition and where we
are covering this epic weekend's match
between Magnus Carlsen the reigning king
and American challenger Fabiano Cara
Juana the first American since Bobby
Fischer to contest the undisputed crown
but the match is deadlocked after eight
games four points of four magnets and
four points for Fabi as neither player
has won a game yet yes it's been all
drawls but such a large variety of draws
including soccer or one player was very
close to Kaplan absolutely well Jennifer
it's great to be back we have seen an
epic fight as you were mentioning game
one was a huge huge chance a victory for
Magnus he let that slip away and then in
game 8 the roles were reversed
Fabiana had what looked like the makings
of victory he was way ahead on us on the
clock his preparation was terrific he
had a waterless position all he needed
this 2/3 accurate moves made one
hesitant move H 2 H 3 the guy gets away
indeed extremely accurate by Magnus and
that's been the theme of this match
sometimes big advantages but if you let
it slip it slips completely away and as
we see the the game has begun yes and
you're gonna be happy because English
you know I was saying earlier that
perhaps since he's been getting such
good positions is FOB being a thief were
that maybe he would play for a Queens
gambit declined anyway right but instead
you play the very principled c45 exactly
now Magnus with the white pieces has not
been getting any advantages he's tried
d4 he's tried Eve for his part and he's
tried c4 got something here
yeah c4 has been his best bet as
previously played the players are
repeating the one English game that
occurred before in that English game
fabbi did play d5 c-65 Knight takes d5
Bishop Shih Tzu and played the line that
Grisha cos single-handedly making
popular with Bishop c5 Abby got a draw
in that game but Magnus had the pressure
throughout we'll see if Magnus has
created some chances for himself and
we're gonna take a look at the World
Championship format for those of you who
are just joining us over Thanksgiving
weekend well we're in our best of 12
games so six and a half gives you the
victory you see we have a luxurious
three part time control and a prize fund
of over a million euros there were no
draw offers before Black's xxx move as
for the schedule we've got four
classical games left as you can see
starting on Thanksgiving you play a game
and your Rast so we're getting to the
tensest part of the match and the
players are getting even more as to
surprise their opponents tiebreaks if
needed are gonna be on November 28th the
Wednesday but we've got grandmaster
Maurice Ashley because this isn't the
only World Championship in the world
right now
the women are fighting in
khanty-mansiysk and Maurice has a story
about the ups and downs of today well
let's just start actually with yesterday
as these two gladiators have really been
punching at each other and Katarina lag
no landed the first blow while we were
resting they were playing and she won a
and ending a rook and Bishop versus rook
and Bishop of opposite color ending and
now today drawing the same type of
ending Joe and June will be kicking
herself as she had multiple chances to
win today but it ended in a fighting
draw and Katarina like no the Russian
will she bring it back home to her
motherland as she attempts to close the
deal tomorrow a draw wins her the match
and she will have the white pieces
leading to one Jew engine down for the
first time in any of her matches she had
been cruising before now but this
fighter has shown her stuff Katarina
like no remember that nine
game epic match against polka Deena just
to survive well if she does win tomorrow
does you engine in a must-win game there
will be a tie break and it'll be best of
rapid to start two games and then blitz
followed by even quicker blitz and then
if necessary a sudden-death Armageddon
game well that certainly is a
interesting match and classic indeed but
we have a fact for you that Fabi fans
are not going to appreciate in the
entire history of World Chess
Championship matches
we're going back to 1986 when they saw
started only seven were tied after eight
games guess what the champion prevailed
in every single one 1989 steinege
tugarin was the first and then the last
being Anand L fun I now needing a
tie-break to actually win that one but
this is not affect that Bobby's handlers
are going to tell him that probably
avoid all TV screens and hope he's not
asked that in the press conference
because clearly it is a fact that
Carlsen will appreciate well they did
start off in that variation and we see
some new moves coming in so let's jump
right to it
Thank You Maurice and indeed that's not
a fun field back the world champion is
won every match Wow from that situation
we have seen the English with the same
move order as their previous English
played between these two great players
d5c takes d5 Knight takes d5 Bishop g2
again in the past there's always been
this ambush tactic against this knight
on d5 Knight takes e5 was such a feared
threat everybody and I mean everybody
automatically retreated they're nice to
b6 I've had numerous games where 96 was
played Bishop c5 it's a kind of a
wrinkle introduced by Alexander Grishka
key as he says I'm not afraid of this
ambush tactic being played and modern
theory today has been castles castles d3
rook E
and I'm thinking Bishop g5 is a twist a
different approach and after Bishop g5
and we seen the move Knight takes c3
well I'm not sure did he play yet or not
looks like yeah looks like he has now
yes did yeah yeah because here's here
was my thinking was that after f6 Knight
takes d5 Queen takes d5 Bishop d2 lers
to lurch the Queen out to the d5 square
making it a potential for Knight g5 and
Queen b3 check ideas so after Bishop g5
let me just update my board and that big
you I beg your pardon he did take on c3
as expected Knight takes c3 avoiding
that variation we talked about this last
time as well in the last time that
Magnus leads before about how taking on
c3 at first seems like a big edge for
white because you captured towards the
center gaining control of the key before
square which is such a big part of
blacks counter playing these dragon like
structures not only that you give white
the B file which is actually even more
powerful than the C file but what is the
reason for black men doing this terrible
you I'm anti positional loop well a lot
of its concrete tactics that getting in
the movie for quickly is counter
balancing it yeah and at the same time
blacks development well let's just
continue yeah f7 f6 he does gain a tempo
against the bishop as he blocks the
threat to his queen well returning to
favor and attacking the bishop the
bishop dropped all the way back to the C
1 square Y c1 well the only alternatives
well the alternative squares III white
wants to avoid as you say that line
where you could take take and play e4
and if you put your bishop back on d2
actually if hamper
White's idea that whites problem is that
this knight on f3 doesn't have very good
squares to move to the d4 squares is
attacked by the pawn on e5 the g5 square
is defended by the pawn on f6 and Magnus
plays the move Bishop c1 because he's
anticipating that in the near future
he'll move his knight from F 3 to D 2
and then hence on to the e4 square so
Bishop c1 Bishop e6 and I believe we're
caught up with the players as we really
do have a reverse Sicilian dragon if you
will and Maurice what's the current
state of theory in this position or or
like thereof or lack thereof in fact we
have this position that has been seen by
theory of course quite a few times not
that many games it turns out but still
enough games for us to take a look at
the main move Bishop d2 which is what
Magnus played in game 1 we also have 94
Knight takes on d5 Knight g5 a3 Queen to
b3 lots of tries mr. t5 has only been
tried once that we can find in the
database and this was a player whose
rating was 2195 2195 we're talking about
640 or so points lower rated than magnus
carlsen
or these two players in fact so this is
not a popular move 93 was played in that
game by his opponent and after f6 the
move Bishop to e3 as opposed to Bishop
to c1 was played yessir you're wrinkling
your nose i can see that allowing this
trade black went on to win this game so
this game no doubt it looked as as
though Fabi played very very quickly
after Bishop g5 and must have looked at
this move as well as it's one of the
options and it's an aggressive one
because it makes a point it's attacking
your queen so you've got to look at
forced moves and now they're in a new
position so this position we see here
Bishop c1 Magnus's move is new to theory
and then we had Bishop e6 followed
pretty promptly thereafter
did fabbi play after this move Bishop c1
Maurice Bishop e6 which is obviously
very consequent move you're developing a
piece you're about to play Queen d7
White's best piece is this Bishop on g2
and many times you start angling for its
trade but now comes the surprise for me
I thought that Magnus was going to play
Knight d2 Jennifers also mentioned a
rook b1 and even something to be said
for an a4 and Bishop c1 idea for a very
dragon like moves I mean for me the most
obvious and direct and they're right use
the the the term best-looking moved to
my eyes would have been 92 I could have
also made a very strong argument for a4
played Bishop b2 so what he said that's
exactly what he's saying he's not the
normal plan not at all
usually kind of I guess what I guess the
reason it's not normally the plan
normally when we flip the colors if you
could get in d5 and the Sicilian it's
always considered quite great yes but
this is a little different because it
seems inevitable that upon playing d4
your opponent's gonna be able to get any
four well amongst other things this pawn
on d3 does a very nice job of defending
c4 and E 4 so for example that's a play
but should be 6 then I go go ahead just
go ahead and play d4 a lot of green felt
players would be very very happy that
this that this square coming to d5 with
the direct threat of just taking on f3
and winning upon taking on f3 as you
mentioned before already Jenny 1 v e4
kind of getting a lock in the center
maybe one day again again Green fell
players would love to put a knight on c4
especially against this Bishop on b2 and
you're probably forced to play something
like III just to defend your pod and
then as you mentioned
at night a five no yes no question about
it and also does f5 f3 it does look very
puzzling to play for the for the central
push d3 d4 but again once Magnus put his
Bishop on b2 oh well let's let's
conceive over there's another way could
he really be thinking that he wants to
play c4 and again I would say 92 94 or
92 and 93 would you yeah but why would
you play for should be 2 and then c4 you
could always make I don't know maybe he
wants to play more but something like a
4 to keep the d4 moving in reserve and a
2a okay so let's go back for a second so
I understand the move a for right away
as you have ideas of a 5 in Queen a form
Bishop a 3 right
but if you're gonna play a 4 I really
think you're playing for Bishop a 3 not
for Bishop b2 true but I said once you
play for it the response might not peep
it should be 6 ok so let's say I'll just
ask what I think you wouldn't have
played Bishop d6 so maybe that's what's
Magnus is thinking Bishop e2 we should
be fixing that a4 and Bishop e6 wasn't
the most useful move okay arguing that
maybe we should be too was as useful as
Bishop e6 well it oftentimes happens
that because you have the open V file
whether you use that B file for rook e1
or queen b1 your end up winning a tempo
against b7 the Bishop on c5 is hanging
back to safety and you kind of stop a
frontal attack against the pawn so this
should be solutely 92 wonderful move I'm
all for it Queen d7 idea let's just
complete development
before looking to play Bishop AIDS it
feels to me that fabbi
is going to be very satisfied with the
outcome of today's this opening into
fabi's opening and you got to say the
regardless of who's winning the match
the team team Bobby has been terrific no
I mean I did say like it's not
completely fair question because magnets
like doesn't necessarily direct his team
to give him like big big slashing that
he wants something that's just like a
little bit a little bit chill with is
this even a smaller what do you mean by
fair when you say fair what do you mean
I mean that the style the style and
directives of the two players are so
different that you can't compare one
team exactly to the other game sure and
and and fab ease one players they need
four and the other reason the others
play more types of openings as well
right so as you say Magnus directs his
team like get me positions where I am
play where my opponent you know I'm not
in my opponent's preparation and
everything's prepared but having said
that let's get into it
who would you give Maurice an edge whose
team has outperformed the other in the
opening well sorry if if we can only go
by the results of the games themselves
or the positions themselves then clearly
Fabiano has had the edge in preparation
so if you're gonna give it to the team
are you gonna safe the team's the reason
is the team or is it the reason the
leadership and foggy side saying this is
the kind of thing I want to do mmm then
you can you can split the difference the
fact is he has clearly I'll prepared
Magnus or outfoxed him maybe not I'll
prepared him but on Foxton gotten to the
kind of positions that he wants and is
directing the opening tenor off the mat
so far you actually sometimes I think
Peter laco who will have later on the
show Grandmaster laco he talked about
this idea of preparation preparation
sometimes it's not about what you
prepared it's what you actually got into
and if you
happen to get into lines that favor you
you can feel good about yourself and
then you'll feel great about your
preparation but if the opponent is
starting to get you on a back foot in
just one little wrinkle suddenly your
main preparation go out the door and
sometimes you have to toss it out the
door for example when Kasparov against
chronic which is a big example of this
was facing off against to Berlin he
could have easily said you know what
after a couple of games I'm leaving a
Berlin thing alone let me go to my other
gigantic possible data jag antic
database with other variations but he
obstinately followed with the berlin
berlin berlin and couldn't break that
berlin wall down and that cost him the
match so you're not seeing necessarily
all of Magnus's preparation so that
makes it maybe look like his team is
probably be doing a worse job that said
from what we have seen it does seem that
Fabiano has out prepared him in this
match right
if you will his team has well one of the
things that I was very very critical for
Magnus about is that petrov where he
played this really really pathetic night
d3 i mean it's sort of like oh god it's
great yeah limp squid of an idea yeah so
like the point is six months ago in
Berlin Fabiana car you wanna is the
Challenger Magnus knew it and he says to
his team okay guys come on you've got
six months to come up with some great
ideas against the Petra and they come up
with this absolute rubbish no that's
unacceptable that was really really
really bad I do believe we have some
moves and I think it was based on the
move d4 by the way so after Bishop b2
let me just refresh my board because I'm
looking as you as you predicted yeah the
very useful movie should be six in d4
and we were saying we'd like to move
Bishop d5 or Bishop c4 just immediately
trying to get some white squares because
that's the logical you should counter to
be for giving up the key light square on
d3 giving up control of e4 right which
one do you like more I'm not even sure
because I like them both Bishop d5 but
I'm also looking at night
five right away tonight I do have the
move nights which will win back I'm not
I'm not sacrificing upon this basically
what I'm saying and I'm getting this
very nice and useful tempo but my
knee-jerk reaction if I was playing a
blitz game because I probably park my
bishop in the middle of the board go for
that line where you said Jen you got to
be concerned that I may capture upon by
capturing on f3 I think you had to play
III here to just just to shore up this
pond right and then you're getting a
position where again I think a lot of
players would be oh wait a minute did I
blender something along the D file I
have to make sure that I don't walk into
some yeah it's some kind of yeah
although I think see if I can be met by
working five so it must be something
different like just a pin yeah I suspect
that can play again the same as before
this night day five we didn't find a
good antidote again thinking well 395
well but but I'm also thinking if I can
play Bishop d5 I'm provoked the movie
three without moving my knight right
like the bishop on defy is very good
like we're just very happy with this
Bishop parked on the center of the board
eyeballing both flanks and then you can
say okay I've provoked the movie three
let me put my knight on a five I've got
some really nice squares and I think
black will be again a very successful
outing for the black pieces and we're
seeing it throughout the match I mean
black has been dictating the the course
of the match and I don't understand why
this is happening normally it's a big
advantage to have white Maurice we think
Jennifer and I reckon that he's happy
you know into my eyes as a human player
as you guys are I think this this looks
good for black but I am so mystified by
the fact that Magnus play this variation
a very forcing line pretty much with
Bishop g5 Bishop c1 play bishop
- and d4 gotta dig a little bit deeper
there's nobody he's just waltzing into a
position where black has simple
blockading chances and that's the end of
that that just can't be right that
sounds too weird - fairy tale for the
player with black to think so my concern
about this for this formation is that
the move Knight c3 you mentioned that
this is a reverse dragon
yeah but the knight takes c3 move is not
something that happens that is when
white plays white normally doesn't like
to take on c6 in any Sicilian because it
strengthens the pawn formation bringing
upon to the c3 squared so for as far as
black is concerned when you see Knights
a c6 happen in a dragon you think you
better show me something because my
Center is gonna be good forever now
Magnus got it as white so Knight takes
c3 it happened right here Bishop c5
Knight c3 so although he did lose major
Tempe in this position he got a
concession 93 BC 3 where he has that
extra center of control and he
immediately went for trying to get more
from the center with this move so the
question is can these pawns be fully
restrained or is there any way for black
4 for white to change the formation or
build the formation because obviously we
know their threats i mean ii 4 is a nice
little move and if it d5 happens
c4 follow up all that will be a lot of
energy for white so you played the move
Bishop d5 and I'm gonna play
I saw the move devil's advocate we put
in the move III here what do you do next
you want to play Knight a5 and now check
out this engine move takes takes and
Queen c2 now the point is to bring
something along this line very fast and
see what's going to happen next maybe
get an e4 pit your bishop is a little
exposed in this position so you have to
now make moves to solidify your position
probably well I'm gonna let you move c6
which is a a very natural first engine
move as a matter of fact at now rook to
d1
let's say and now the only thing about
this position to note is this pawn on e5
right yeah definitely we this Bishop is
biting on granite but you might say the
salient features really come down to the
C 4 square or the bishop on b2 right
right so that's an issue now the engine
gives Knight d2 in this position and
happily willing to trade off the Finca
doe bishop which you wouldn't expect is
a good idea but also aiming to get in c4
and to try to prove that this piece is
not that great what's happening is this
the kind of position he investigated the
engines by the way and now giving this
as slightly better for whites now is it
really that much better that you'd be
worried about this line not that clear
but you do have to admit they're sort of
like square weaknesses in blacks
position right now the e4 square could
become weak c4 is coming in the position
this point is isolated if it's a
position that he investigated very very
carefully even if it's equal ish white
knows what's going on you don't have
prep this is not preparation that Bobby
would have suspected
I think Bishop g5 Bishop c1 with the
idea of going to be 2 to play d4 and let
me blockade your position so surprise is
a weapon in chess is this a surprise
that he has prepared something along
these lines where Fabi could not be in
his preparation and he has gotten the
edge in terms of the kind of positions
that may happen that's a big
consideration remember he played c4 what
a week ago yeah so this is important we
can't just judge it based on the the
optics it looks as though Magnus has
gotten the position he wanted on the
board whether or not it's good we're
gonna see that would be some deep breath
if true Maurice that's extraordinary by
the way this is our guest lineup looks
exciting Jennifer that's right three
appearances by Gary Kasparov basically
at every round after today Gary will be
with us which is so thrilling and today
we have Peter let go coming on what an
outstanding coincidence it was that he
was on I dare with us when this -
Michael my dad was watching and leader
was like what what happened did you like
call Peter up after he saw it with a
special confidence let's get the
foremost specialist in the world to take
us through this mission accom I don't we
of course how often it is that you
mentioned in such a lineup and you don't
mention Anand this drama no I was
getting there I don't have crumb we're
gonna have an out of course the lake Oh
today will be arriving shortly to give
us his insights fantastic commentator by
the way but also Vichy joining us Vichy
joining Gary it won't be even be at the
same time they're coming on at different
times right so we'll be able to enjoy
their to varying insights and then
crumbling if game 12 is necessary
Wow then kramnik will be on as well
there's some interesting World
Championship titles between those huh
coming how many can you count how many
matches have those played I know Gary's
got I can't even count Gary 7 World
Championship matches for Gary but the
first one was an aborted match so we're
gonna say he's a six-time no no no no no
no what are you talking about he played
five doormen so I got a measure of
Karpov you're saying you're saying as a
title holder cuz he did play against
Carl title winner as a title winner
right but remember you play Kramnik
short and uh none so that's three more
but he held the title for six and lost
one right he's played in eight matches
one aborted one lost and six one and
then kramnik played against him and laco
and two men and two Paulo
that's three that he won that he won and
then lost uh nan that's right
uh none he's got so many of them alive
he's got five titles but he also has
played in matches knockout tournament
you got who start so that's that's what
I 6 and 5 and 3 so that's 14 World
Championships titles but just between
those three and then lako of course was
a challenger amazing stuff I can't wait
I just really loved the interview with
crabman
and I mean on on is so great because
when you interview him especially when
it's not about a tournament that he's
playing in he's so honest and
matter-of-fact about things I see his
opinions because she's depth of
understanding and preparation is so deep
the opinions aren't what everybody else
is saying right so he's both objective
but also his objectivity is better it
seems it seems that doesn't it I mean
and especially where fabbi is concerned
in this match he he didn't see you know
this very very big advantage that so
much so many in the chess world were
giving Magnus like they were just saying
Magnus is going to win and he's like
even if it goes to Tiger he believes
that it's not as big a edge for Magnus
it's a lot of people think and you know
I've seen that opinion from Annan echoed
in some of the Vettii market and on top
of that I really thought more about what
he said and I really couldn't agree more
I think one thing that he was mentioning
how it's very different from saying okay
Fabi you have to play these 10 super
grandmasters and Robin and Magnus you
have to and I'm not even going to tell
you who they are obviously Magnus a big
hedge then yeah but we're talking about
the preparation and the one-on-one
matchup always and the preparation can
make the rapid game feel a lot longer
they can you imagine and Bobby got that
piece of preparation he had yesterday in
our two days ago in a rapid lights-out
that's right this is what the tiebreak
would look like for rapid games game 25
plus a 10 second increment in case of a
2-2 tie they would play at the best of
two blitz games Jennifer and that would
be repeated up to five times and I'm
going to cut you right now Lee I'm
getting married man you can't repeat
that repeat it up to five times does
that mean six survived
about the anon gelfand match in
particular so Vichy at the time of that
match was considered one of the greatest
rapid chess players in the world whereas
Gelfand was hardly even listed in the
top ten and rapid Delfin was always
admired as a great classical player but
not a blitz player and not a rapid
player so going into that match and into
that tie break everybody just gave
enormous enormous advantage to Anand to
win the match and tiebreaks
and Anan barely squeaked through with
the two and a half one and a half
victory winning won one of the four tie
break games in Gelf and missing a win so
I mean in tiebreaks
you know experience counts for so much
but as does preparation as does
confidence and you know there's just
who's playing well Maurice he's there
like Magnus a lot it's not just like
Magnus you know people are making a big
deal about Magnus is HP in rapid and
bullets which is obviously the case he
has proven time again that he's the
number one player in the world and both
specialties but also recognized another
stat I'm gonna give you a little sad
that you may not like in the tiebreaks
that we've had in the World
Championships yeah you know people decry
the form of the format oh the tiebreaks
it's not good you should just give the
champion the title you know it might be
lucky that the guy wins because it's
it's rapid and blitz and not classical
we've had three tiebreaks
so far right we've had chronic Apollo's
we've had anon Gelfand
and we've had Carlsen car yakking right
in all three the champion one right all
three right so we talked about after
eight games the champ wins all of all
the matches and seven also in all the
tiebreak s-- the champion has one that's
okay and poker we need like a thousand
iterations to feel home to feel
concerned you're talking about you're
saying concern you're talking from a
foggy point of view I'm not talking from
that point if you I'm just talking from
the facts okay reality is the champion
has won all the time so far that's not
proof of anything no no I'm just saying
that
very small sample size it is a small
sample size indeed but that said you
don't have to go to just Carlson being
better at wrap it in Blitz then Fabi is
you can also go to history and you'll
see the trend you know the champion
there's a reason why we've only had 16
world champions in the history of the
game since 1886
we've only had how long the classical
line that is we've only at 16 there's a
reason why because the champ usually
he's able to defend his title now Sam
has gotten some favors like by Vinick
when he got some rules that really fake
her to him in terms of a rematch clause
for example or Karpov he got nominating
a rematch clause but also that seeded
into the finals of the of the candidates
matches versus Kasparov so you we saw
him play because prob again and again
and again a little bit of favoritism
there but still the trend is champions
tend to hold the title in chess even
when the rules don't necessarily favor
the champion like now in the 12 game
matches where the champion has that to
win in the tiebreaker
so it's tall odds for Fabi
but of course anything can happen the
Greek retook again he said that in chess
we build statistical models after a few
games Worth and poker we used we use
statistics when it's about 10,000 cases
in fact it's true it's a funny thing in
poker there's like statistics that you
use to play against your opponent and
one common folly is that there will be a
very small number of hands like a
hundred hands and that somebody will use
it to statistics only having a hundred
hands and you know that's usually seen
as like a fish move exactly because it's
such a small sample size that if you use
the statistics you instead of just using
your you know normal plays or default
plays you would be making a huge error
often because it could be that those
hundred hands or something weird about
them so then when you start to get like
a thousand iterations or ten thousand as
great Jake said then you can be like
okay that's enough so that we kind of
like so basically the bottom line is
Bobby's gonna win the tiebreak
I went from A to Z there is like Mike
Mike there's a lot of people on Twitter
from Eric Rosen to Anna Rudolph to
Kousaka boot ski to Simon Williams they
all went to a party last night when you
got to the party you had to pick a foggy
mask or a Magnus mask and you played
like a blitz tournament so it was like a
sea of five years versus eeeh Magnus's
of you obviously the masked ball the
mask was kind of like that so like you
could see the board so wasn't just like
blindfold test the math coverable sounds
like we missed our invite by the way
because only because Maggie pardon me
fabbi has got into a deep thing and we
were just been talking maurice about
that Bishop d5 very unusual and I must
say I found it slightly disconcerting
your suggestion of d5 d5 Queen c2 I can
make an argument I think a pretty decent
argument that white has a lot to play
for in that position I'm just wondering
a move that you resist playing but how
good or how bad is it
'if I've Eve or attacking the knight the
knight would drop back to presumably to
d2 an argument might be made 491 but
then I play f5 and obviously you'd like
to play C for you'd have to defend the
pawn on eath on d4 with the move III and
then how would the situation after
Knight a5 get judged well two ways to
play in that position yes instant both
of us would say Queen e2 tried to play
for c4 or something to try to play for
c4 somehow or the other plan is to play
the f3 break right
they both so those are the two plans in
that position I don't see g4 before your
buddy was playing yeah and then taking
on e4 with another interesting question
probably with the bishop right but
anyway so that's I'm just looking at all
the breaks right I'm looking at all
potential pawn growth c4 expansion three
G for F 3 and g4 now trying to make c4
happen with Queen e2 does but but f3 but
if you play have three though let's
start with f3 I want to only go that if
you play f3 this is a normal pot
formation right yes this is something
that we've seen happen many times
absolutely here's my problem again
fabi's assessing this right now right
fabi's assessing everything right now he
knows when d4 came on the board they
came with a thud it came quickly the
idea of Bishop b2 Bishop c1 Bishop d2
and d4 came instantly and I has there
been any game where Fabi has had to
worry about the opening moves so far
like any game any game and the I don't
think there's any game that I can recall
maybe the other English but no there's
nothing where Fabia's has played slowly
as a result of the opening itself so now
and if you guys remember one please let
me know because I don't remember any no
it looks like oh he's returning this
minute it's not just black as white as
well he played he played a line that
that Magnus had to stop and got into
heavy time pressure yesterday two days
ago so Robbie has been in the driver's
seat as far as the openings of concern
except maybe gave one where you also
played what he wanted to play and it
just didn't work out position that he
wanted but now he's in a position where
a Magnus has clearly prepared the setups
and this is not oh I prepared it just to
get a playable position he prepared this
one specifically that d4 move is on the
board because he suspected right here
that he was very clear on what is going
to happen in the next five to 10 moves
he's very clear Magnus's what are the
possibilities from here it's not oh
let's just set up this position where
black can get a blockade let me get rid
of my auto-update so I can analyze he's
not gonna set up a position after this
where black and Bishop d5 was played but
he's not gonna play the move d4 and say
black can just play Bishop d5 set up a
blockade with ninety five and then shut
me down
oh yeah great opening preparation team
you know congratulations you're fired
no he said if you're gonna you're gonna
put me at Bishop C 1 and this d4 idea
and give black bloc eight clear
blockading options bishop d5 Bishop c4 I
need to know exactly what's happening
next and how are we playing for
advantage and Bishop d5 is now on the
board and Fabi after a long think 30
minutes of thought and what this
magnitude instantly Queen c2 instantly
that tells you we are in Magnus's
preparation still he's clear on what he
wants and Fabi knows he has walked into
it this is a very dangerous moment for
Fabiano Caruana because he is in Magnus
crosses preparation game 8 when
everything from the opening was fab ease
preparation including getting a 40
minute edge on the clock 40 minutes I
guess the match progresses and people
find out when you signal to them this is
what I'm going to be playing as black in
the beginning you're not sure what
they're gonna pick right information you
fishing for information as bishi would
explain it to us and once you find out
what those once you find out what those
black openings are now I you can drill
them can try to you know target and
destroy precisely although I mean last
yesterday's game was even more terrified
from the opening point I thought it was
like it was really scary
yeah and I thought I mean is no like I
don't know if it's on the same level
because again it's not like black has
done anything precipitously wrong like
has black done that's bad that we can
jump on him and say okay I'm gonna
criticize you fabbi for developing your
pieces and center-right you know I mean
it's already such a sharp risky opening
that it's kind of natural that there
might be a nuke and cranny or where you
get worse is that what you're saying
well I'm just saying how you know you
you you have to win the game you got to
punish money bad play you to distinguish
between yesterday I mean two days ago
like why why was it different because
especially cause just too risky opening
so you really have to have everything
not oh no no in this fashion akov Magnus
this Bishop d2 a5 he reacted very poorly
with business g5 not shutting him down
with a six and A five so but but there
was a small window like 85 it was only
g5 yeah you think you saw a big age
after f4 you were lauding the no I'm
saying that I think that Magnus should
have taken the time to play a six and A
five so I I would I would say that was a
first mistake and then ii was g5 so to
my mind it wasn't enough to make one
mistake but there was two mistake that
gave fabbi the big edge now in this
position what is it as that fab e's done
that's so bad i understand that it's all
preparation and Magnus's played Queen c2
and he's eyeballing opportunities for
efore as well as takes and you know he's
got me you know he's all going
gangbusters but I'm saying I can't put
my finger on it and say oh no no no this
is a mistake that Magnus can exploit
Magnus is just playing quickly and fine
but it's not like Black has a bad
position and yeah so you might be just
describing the situation after the fact
because in that game the game with the
special car that you're talking about
yeah there wasn't there was Theory when
I went when I went back to the room yeah
looks thing look things up it turns out
that in Correspondence game or in a very
famous
respondent game correspondence game
there is theory in that line that says
that black is perfectly fine up to g5 up
up to g5 he should not Emily should not
have played this idea with g5 g5 was
just a bad move in that position he
should have gone for actually had an
earlier shot by playing 95 immediately
the Bishop f6 idea that was all fine for
him that was all supposed to be fine
that is something you might see as a
one-off if I'm not sure Magnus will want
to go back into this fresh new club at
all but if he does it turns out that
black is fine in that opening and he
could allow what happened in the game to
happen yet again will he do it will we
see it again we don't know that position
however was extremely sharp double-edged
and you're making a great point yes here
it's hard to know what he did he
developed his pieces the only thing you
can point to if you're gonna point to
anything is Knight takes on c3 giving
white the superior centre for the long
run if White's given the favor of a
couple of moves yeah White's gonna
overrun black sure if White's just given
the favor of a couple of moves so black
has to respond well right now not that
he's worse not that he's doing badly at
all but white does have strategic
Trump's we see that it's very clear this
Center is big and if it expands then
you've got problems so right so if
you're gonna argue the little challenge
of Knight c3 not being what you want in
a Sicilian it's just a reverse or
otherwise you don't really want to take
on c3 and give the player that big
center if you can shut it down then
you're good that's a big if has Magnus
looked into all the fine points and said
mm-hmm and his team know what it's not
so easy as people think people might
think at first blush and yes 93 is a
mistake from a strategic standpoint that
would be the only argument yes okay if I
can play concretely for a second let's
just let's just take all the
subjectiveness out of it and not let's
say I'm black and I want to I want to
shut everything down and I want to prove
equality as soon as possible I will take
on d4 he takes e5 takes d4
see 364 I will play Bishop b4 attacking
your queen so again I want to play very
concretely where do you want to move
your queen that's a good question let's
put it on I want to play Queen again for
to avoid you because you can't believe
it's a c5 if I check you know in in
every case whether you play Queen b3
Queen C for Queen a4 I'm gonna play
Queen d5 so you would like to play Queen
a4 I'd like to post up with my queen in
the middle of the board eyeballing a pin
your knight on f3 can't move because
Bishop g2 and I'm just rock solid in the
center is what I want to say its Queen D
fortune all right let's go back okay
please I don't see how to push through
there and check if I play check Queen b3
or Queen c4 check in both cases I will
meet that with Queen d5
now you can trade Queens and play e3 but
in that ending middle game ending I'm
not that upset because your your Center
is pretty much fixed okay let's go for
take c3 takes takes on d5 III so pretty
much you wanted to avoid Bishop f3
followed by Knight takes d4 okay so now
I'm figuring the center is pretty closed
let me get frisky I want to play c5 so
first give me ideas like c3 now you're
gonna take on 83 i na 2 really ships boy
you're testing my reason I just a knight
is kind of know it you have a 5 a 5 to
bring it out okay Bishop d2 it doesn't
have a lot of places to go I need okay
let's just show this for the audience so
even though my knight is trapped on this
a2 square I
have given myself a recourse to retreat
with the move a five I wish I had some
kind of tempo game I know you guys want
to beat up on me today why do I so he's
playing a very concrete recipes a lot
what you're saying yeah but this ocean
yes so this but this is the thing if I
be if Magnus lets this happen
the LightSquared blockade with then you
have to really ask the quiet like what
did he prepare this morning like not
this morning its whole week like if he
just lay this simple thing happens I'm
trying to understand why he would play
like this because all of us are looking
at it and saying from a logical
standpoint blacks should be fine exactly
so looking at the other side you've got
to imagine that Magnus came with some
weapon he saw the most natural moves on
the board blockade the position with
your bishop of course you have to have
something cool against the most natural
moves because if you could just do what
you just did and fabi's doing right now
the capture and bishop before and by the
way the engine saying that even bishop
d5 is the best way to play not even
Queen defined right not even more
concretely because you do have to deal
with the threat of capturing on f3 and
that is something that's real and by the
way e2 is hanging and by the way you too
is hanging so Queen c2 a Bishop b4 and
are we really going to see a repetition
run like this
that's literally taking white and just
throwing it out of the window so that
will be stunning and what is and we have
we we do have bishop we do have to
capture guys it easy with the back this
is crazy he did capture he did go to
this point and now Bishop b4 is on the
board
I believe Queen b3 check is also been on
board okay but doesn't matter because
you have a threat of taking on f3 and
taking on d4 that's real that's like oh
that's coming very fast so it doesn't
if you repeat or not I mean this is we
are you saying there's you saying
there's no way out of it I'm not really
sure is the interest giving us best what
to do with your queen
go back defend bishop here do you wan
that snot even chest
by the way showed up wearing a bandage
on one eye what
something happened in sports yesterday
piracy how they say that they say that
with Magnus it's uh the rest day is the
most dangerous day well I know I
remember him invite cons a playing a
soccer football match where man there
was some serious tackling going on I was
like this guy is the world champion he's
gonna get himself hurt I mean he takes
his sports very seriously I mean he's
very competitive guy he doesn't like to
lose in anything Maurice this is really
bizarre a repetition almost Imani wait
dip like Queen do you watch yeah he did
go all the way but he not not with no it
went well no it went bishop before Queen
b3 checked gen yes Queen dy yeah
protecting the pawn on e to presumably
he's not afraid of Bishop takes f3 and
Knight takes e4 can we just see why he's
not afraid of Bishop takes f3 now taking
the pawn is ridiculous because then so
you have to take with a knight force
majeure right now I'm a little bit
afraid of Bishop takes d4 Queen b3 check
so let me just capture immediately with
the night you can take down here but
then
me too with a check so if I play Bishop
t4 and then it should takes d4 my idea
is that a bishop takes d4 I'll play
Queen B three tracks followed by rook to
d1 exam and then you'll be a happy
camper because you'll have me in a pin
and you're your odds on favorite to win
this pawn
you can't play Queen Emma's piece
because your this is a cool construction
normally Queen f6 would save the day
after Bishop takes d4 I will be obliged
to easy after Queen right and now again
you do have this check and rook d1 and
yes and I presume I mean even though
it's bishops of opposite color I just
feel it's more comfortable to have white
yeah I don't think it's it's a huge edge
or anything but okay and and fabbi is
not forced to capture oh no no I don't
think he'll take it either just build up
the pressure to try to pick it later
maybe like Queen d7 and rook b8 and then
like well obviously at some point we're
gonna be threatening to choke up
straight and then you're gonna be worth
to play III right right you one day
could you just ask the chess engines
after the move Queen b3 I was always I
had it while not in my heart but it
certainly is an intent
my intention was also always to play
Queen d5 how did the engines assess that
ending after Queen b3 Queen d5 I
understand fabbi played the move Bishop
d5 but did they think white was
significantly that slightly better just
like two-tenths of a pawn yes exactly
point two five and even now going even
bigger with 0.47 has the more analysis
goes into this exact position saying
that white clearly has an edge here and
this ending is is all about these pawns
and the potential small weakness here
and this position I think you played in
night before in the last position and
move a three allowing your knight to
come in if you want to a lot of c3
and now you better scramble really
quickly to deal with what's happening
with your night on the d3 square because
after C 5 C 5 well see if I are you
gonna put a pawn on c4 I was I was oh I
see and then maybe Knight d2 after c4 2
and then my mine and also this is coming
as well this is not a simple ending at
all so that's a good again the idea of
this clear repetition and easy play
Magnus is still in his preparation Queen
d1 looks strange to be sure but now
going also sucess e the supercomputer
watching this set C is giving white 0.25
advantage really a clear but small but
clear advantage to white again because
of the structure the small weakness on
this side the center pawns the blockade
is not something that's super fixed as
e3 and 92 going back to our big board
back here yeah Queen d1 III with 92 will
lift this blockade it's not just gonna
be something that you're able to
establish just like that and maintain so
it's still a sharp an interesting
position we are still in Magnus analysis
Fabia's down now almost 55 zero minutes
on the clock
Wow factories down Mac sorry Fabi
I said factory hey that would be a
super-duper chess player yeah but Bobby
is down heavily on the clock and Magnus
is in his preparation don't know what
accident got any eyepatch and all that
but he is very confident you know
accident here he's got his position that
he wanted wow I still find it remarkable
now I know why I like the English if you
got a point 2 5 and you and you take a
move like Queen c2 backwards you make a
retreat move and you still have an
advantage that's something good about
the English and you could say well in
that case yeah sure there's something
good about the Sicilian as well
and I would say that but just just to
point out the obvious magnets are
totally in his preparation bobby has
burned nearly forty minutes off the
clock so right we're not shocked here
that Magnus didn't go for the repetition
no because idea here well and again one
of the things that as a chess
grandmaster you're very aware of is the
chess clock I mean we tend to think of
the position the chess position the
chess position only in fact the chess
clock is a part of the equipment and as
a chess grandmaster I'm very aware when
my opponents burning a lot of clock
looks a little bit nervous and that
gives me the confidence that I want to
play on when I see my opponent is really
behind on the clock I think I can
exploit my opponent's time trouble so
definitely Magnus feeling getting a
positive signal I want to say from
Fabian the clock I would like to add to
that first of all I want my move f6 back
to f7 not happy with that the other
thing I will point out is the idea of
fortresses are we talking about is
impregnable fortress as Magnus has said
he doesn't believe in fortresses in the
game against Fabi his fortress was not
gonna hold up if Bobby had found those
supercomputer moose all right there's
also the same thing about blockades you
can if you could set up an impregnable
blockade then of course you're set up
and you just smile but if you can't
establish that then the guy's pawns are
going to eventually start rolling so
white is looking forward to the fact
that here you have the bishop there I I
see you you're guarding e4 for now I see
you right but if you don't have any
other type of great play in the position
if you're not playing for anything for
example right here black really means to
move c5 that would be his only pawn
break like how do you expand your
position how do you improve your
position pawn breaks open up lines for
your pieces well if you can if white can
suppress this move c5 then eventually
why
we'll move like III weensy to night back
to D to bring something to the center
and play for efore right that's what's
going to happen so white is very clear
on what's coming in the future
black in the on the other hand is trying
to maintain this blockade at all cost if
he's only planning to maintain the
blockade and white is playing to create
energy in the position to expand these
Center pawns then sooner or later
what like one of those two plans is
gonna happen so the question becomes can
you successfully maintain the blockade
and this is what Magnus's team had to
look into because they could see yeah
you're gonna try to stop me on the light
squares right right we didn't they
didn't come to this position and say
okay yeah this is good enough
here Magnus play this my name's be like
no no wait a minute
the guy's got a great Bishop he's got a
rook on the file he's got any foreigner
control these pieces aren't bad okay he
doesn't have this little weakness but
could we could we look a little bit
deeper a lot deeper the next six seven
ten moves to seek and block black
actually tamp down White's expansion in
this position right that's the critical
question we're gonna have to analyze
move after move after move there's a lot
of midnight oil burned on this one to
see whether or not it's really something
that black is equalizing well exactly
well you put the strategic concepts for
both players in a clear perspective it's
all about white being able to one day
very very slowly it doesn't matter how
long it takes him white very slowly one
day wants to be able to lift this
blockade on the light square by being
able to play the move e3 e4 and take
over the game black on the other hand if
he can maintain the light square
blockade for a long long long time to
come including trading pieces he's gonna
be doing very very well by the way
Jennifer I just wanted to tell our
viewers we've got a very special
fireside chat coming up yeah with two of
our guests Gaspar offing the casbah rock
Kramnik period era that
the reason I spoke about in our fireside
chat well bring it back to London as we
have a fireside chat on a Kramnik at
Caspar Oh
garry kasparov is a name that will
always ring in the history of chess but
one of the big things that happen with
him was he was such a powerful
personality and when he didn't like
something it showed absolutely and he
didn't like the way the World
Championship was being run so after he
beat he beat Karpov their last match he
decided you know what it's time to
professionalize chess that's what he
wanted let's take the world championship
over right
basically it was a hijacking right and
when he played against the Nigel short
in 1993 it was not under the umbrella of
fidei but what under the umbrella of the
newly created professional chess
Association the PCA and if you didn't
like that no because that was their
bread and butter there was a lot of
money fees that they got extracted from
that World Championship match you were
front and center and a lot of the drama
that went on no question about it
Maurice I think of the World
Championship five game five matches from
1984 to 1990s the golden period of chest
and Gary was a real maverick and keep in
mind each and every one of those matches
where multi-million dollar matches and
fita gets 20% nice little prize no
question about it
I remember 1987 they had more than five
million Swiss francs that's 20% to the
fee day that's 1 million suite right
there for the Vita Gary was a Marik he
was a rabble in the Soviet Union when
you didn't think rebels were allowed to
be rebels I mean wasn't the Soviet Union
just one big monolithic organization it
doesn't allow for rebels but Gary
in 1987 wanted to start the grandmasters
Association the GMA I was on the board
of directors and he wanted to
professionalize a sport bringing
commercial
sponsors and he wanted the chess
professionals the top grandmasters in
the world to take control of their
livelihoods and their lives and that was
the GMA and by the time of 1993 rolls
around
Gary's more incensed and more convinced
than ever that feet--a is not acting for
the good of chess but literally for its
own self for its own bureaucrats by now
he's been champ for eight years
oh yeah he's got the gravitas I mean
he's a big star not just a guitar he
transcended he's transcended his sport
and people in the common person is
finding out about this guy garry
kasparov his name is not maybe not
Fischer's level but certainly was it's a
car in the general world exactly I
remember an argument broke out in the
United Nations Council where the u.s.
representative publicly denounced the
Soviet ambassador and called him far off
and the Russians laughed and said no
Kasparov the chess champion of the world
it was like loser Gary's were very very
well known and he had transcended the
sport and there's no question about that
and Gary had some very specific ideas
what he wanted to do and what Vijay was
doing was not cool and him then he plays
Nigel short his first Western Challenger
finally instead of his perpetual
opponent that's who we called Anatoly
Karpov his perpetual opponent he had a
Western Grandmaster from from the UK
Nigel short and he saw this as a clash
of East and West two rival Fisher
Spassky never rose to that level of
interest but he wanted to take that
match and turn it away from what had
often been the case in the past private
money or public money he wanted
commercial sponsors and he thought
that London should be the first ten
million dollar match and feed a
disappointed him with the offerings like
well again he hijacked the match
essentially I used that word strong
terms but it's correct but he took the
match he played with short he crushed
short in their match
meantime feed a continues to organize
its own matches because it says we're
legitimate we're the legitimate
organization and the schism breaks out
in the chess world and that continues
into Anand versus Kasparov or played in
New York in the World Trade Center first
game right 911 yes II 95 I remember
doing the commentary for that and then
five years passed before he finally
plays kramnik and even that was crazy
because sharafat properly qualified
exactly play against it but they
couldn't get a finance letter for
Kasparov versus Sharov rights that he
plays against his student vitamin
vitamin chronic so there you have the
problem from the schism from the world
war two schism which was like who held
the title whose property is the world
championship title so fides attitude was
like hey man were the official guys it's
ours and prior to World War two it was I
don't know like I know I'm the champion
I owned the title it's me
so Gary essentially with the schism
we're saying no the property's mine I
can go and do my own thing and I'm gonna
play this guy this guy this guy except
that came a problem they were back to
the old ways where the finances were
becoming more and more problematic for
Cariocas pile it's funny because when
you think about the age of the private
World Championships it was the 1880s the
end of the 1880s and in the early
nineteen hundred's it passed and now we
have the late 90s and it's back to sort
of private even though Kasparov is
trying to make it into something more of
a commercial enterprise right and it
really didn't work for him the way it
what he wanted it to absolutely not
especially since fidei held their ground
that's a queer gonna battle as much as
possible and then he faces Kramnik and
that was really a nightmare for him
he had been playing so well he'd been
the dominant player number one player
for twenty years how does he play a
match complete match against someone and
he doesn't win one game it's a question
I have no answers for I mean chronic was
absolutely incredible in that match the
Berlin defense is born he played out of
his mind he played the best chess of his
life forever and ever amen
I happen to know on a personal level
that Gary's going through a divorce
something that he never felt back on he
didn't use it as a crusher and excuse
but I will generally genuinely say to
you
he had his distractions but you can't
take it away kramnik one men
gromek wins the match Kasparov never
gets a rematch never love ya retires in
2005 of course the age of dominance of
Kasparov just well T years 20 years of
number 115 years as champion and goes
down as you say as the greatest player
of all time yep I must say as Magic
Johnson said about Michael Jordan when
he said I'm the new sheriff in town you
ain't lyin
that was a bad man and he will always be
remembered as truly one of the greatest
if not the greatest ever absolutely
a question on Twitter from dumbass I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn two squares not one but
it's a little something we call hustle
and you can do that but you have to do
it instantly you can't wait for a move
like that say play King in seven games
you - and I'll try because I'll play for
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think he wanted to know who
Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Chester to work like this I don't think
it does well maybe it does well that's
me regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office of the guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of the
World Chess Championship in London
between Carlson and Kara Juana
we just had a key move yeah the key
decision by the American challenger he's
pleased but should take that three and
we're gonna see you before up on go yes
but additionally white is going to get
the b7 pawn and some play potentially on
the defy we're definitely going to have
a Bishop's of an opposite color middle
game we've got Maurice and I on our
break we're just looking at a very
consequent line that went Queen b3 check
otherwise you would recapture instantly
on f3 but this Queen b3 check does
deserve consideration
clever move it's the kind of move that
if it was winning it would be problem
for a lot of people because it's easy to
forget that you can't go back to d5
because the bishop or the Queen can take
it yeah I like that rule always checking
me but is it a good that's a good I mean
well it's good it's good King h8 Queen
takes f3 Knight takes d4 Bishop takes d4
Queen takes d4 is a kind of a variation
we're looking at e2 e3 why is this if it
moves so important yeah Queen f3 yeah I
was I was attracted to it let's say I'm
getting the pawns on III and f2 the idea
is to shut down the rook on e8 and the
bishop on b6 so that after for example
Queen e5 this is a very typical
middlegame position bishops have
opposite colors I've got the light
squares you've got the dark squares but
you know it's easier to play white and
you know Maurice you like also
recapturing you put leaving the Queen on
v3 and capturing with the bishop on b7
and the whole idea is that from White's
point of view his Kings a little bit
safer and he's never really worried
about the C pawn being a factor
I mean I'll always be on the blockade
and
I'm just saying Magnus will walk out of
this opening saying I got an edge now
the question Maurice is how big an edge
is it is it enough to be a decisive
advantage well there are many questions
to ask and the one that you just asked
is a force of extremely important one
and it's trying to answer it there are
couple of answers we our eyes can tell
that it's a clear edge for white right
that is definitely the case the size of
it is in question
well you access see the supercomputer
that's following a Norwegian
supercomputer that's follow that follows
his Magnus's every move I don't know if
it follows like him playing football and
getting in an accident and hurting his
eye but did it calculate that but it
follows everything happening on the
chess board for sure and it feels that
White's advantage now is pronounced up
to 0.89 almost a full pawn that's a lot
more than I think most of us would give
white in this position that seems huge
almost a pawn very close to 0.8 nine is
$0.89 pawns a hundred Senate process a
full pawn so that seems like a lot now
that said and Bishop F Queen b3 check
was played and the line that we saw with
Bishop takes on f3 so check was played
King moves and Bishop takes was place
where anticipating 9 takes d4 in the
next move this is the main issue for me
this is not a line that probably had to
walk into he saw this position it's very
clear to him that this position could
happen on the board so he must have
decided to make a practical decision at
least I'm gonna guess that he made a
practical decision I'm going to play the
inferior endgame where maybe I'm worse
but I think I can hold because otherwise
you don't go into this position you try
to play some other more complex position
but he must have seen enough poison in
the main position to say I don't think I
can sustain that position for long let
me go into this one and he's playing now
very quickly taken on d4 let me go into
a position where I am going to be worse
but I think I can hold this position it
looks clear to me that this is
defensible
now what that saying is in chess how big
is the draw window is it this big is it
this big is it this big has he gotten
bigger over the years it clearly has
gotten bigger because now the modern
players are able to draw positions that
before you say that guy you're worse
you're gonna lose and they're tenacious
and defense they grew up on computers
defending positions and like it's from
they're from babies milk this is what
you do if you have to save yourself
so they've seen so much of these types
of positions that must be that Fabi
thinks I don't think I'm much worse here
it's clear that I'm worse but I don't
think I'm that much worse that I'm going
to lose this game and the challenge when
you look at this position as now Mischa
takes d4 Queen takes d4 has also
occurred b7 is gonna drop and you look
at this position
how does white win the game despite
having the advantage that you and I were
discussing this yes sir
how does white win the advance of these
pawns looks like it's going nowhere you
don't want to push these pawns which is
your majority is this pawn going up the
board well III could have happened
before there should be seven by the way
I think was our analysis but it wouldn't
matter so let's play it now these pawns
don't want to move because then it opens
up the line for this for this Bishop and
even if they go down to the board a part
getting to e5 doesn't look like
something that's gonna be a successful
operation to create that past one so
that looks difficult yeah so you tried
against me to push the pawn down the
board and maybe put a queen and Bishop
on this diagonal that wasn't very clear
either and winning the D foul it doesn't
look like White's gonna win the default
looks like both pieces both sides will
have a shot on the D file so taking this
position from fabi's point of view now
he must have embraced it and said I
think I can hold his position
you're better congratulations on your
preparation I'll give you this better
and I'll tell you I'm gonna make a draw
yeah that's exactly what he's saying and
here we have the Twitter update
Rebecca's crossing from playing soccer
yesterday poked in the eye
yeah ball in the face upside the head
it looks like more than a ball in the
face is a scar it looks like over his
eye well I had the best tweet about this
elbow rule is you don't talk about chess
bug reference of course it's a fight
that was pretty good that's nice a good
movie or a good tweet obviously it cakes
f3 yeah Grisha apparently targets ensign
is telling us that Magnus is just
clearly better 40-degree check benjamin
Bach is a student here at st. Louis
University a better position and almost
an extra hour on the clock Magnus is
looking to deliver some hits today yes
so he got hit yesterday and now he's
looking to hit back um a lot of people
are saying the same thing
fiddler thinks that the position is a
complete free roll that's a poker term
for us playing for two results exactly
so you basically it would be like
getting a lottery ticket but not paying
for it so you have the candidates win a
lot of money but you don't you know yeah
the biz note there's no big risk I get
all of that and seriously it is a very
nice advantage and I wanted to ask
Maryse because you were describing the
situation in the setup very well and I
think that Bishop takes f3 to my mind is
a kind of a move that you make as black
when you're way behind on the clock and
you're trying to force something yes I
think that in that position let's say
you are in a situation you're trying to
win the millionaire open with the black
pieces ah you don't want to play Bishop
f3 you want to play Queen d7 rook da
port and play for three results
absolutely even if it keeps the game
double-edged and
what have you so taking on f3 is really
either a shocking I am so confident I
can draw this position against you I I'm
going to accept it
or it's a badness judgment by fabbi
going into a position where he didn't
have to give up the advantage so readily
absolutely not and there is it is
unimaginable that he went into this line
by mistake he must have decided I see
your prep I understand you're playing
quickly I need to alter this to a
situation that has clarity now is that
the right thing to do when you are in
trouble when you're behind on the clock
when you're in the guys preparation
under normal circumstances Fabiano
Caruana 99 times out of a hundred I'm
going to tell you this is the one out of
a hundred maybe is maybe it's two or
three will not play Bishop f3 and just
hand you the advantage he look for other
moves and play it out but his opponent
I've been blitzing the move so quickly
and when you're playing in a World
Championship match there's a really
interesting thing Levon Aronian said
some words that I will never forget I
live on of course one of the top players
in the world
he said the World Championship matches
are never great like never great
examples of chess he said the players
never bring their best play to the World
Championship it matters too much they're
too nervous there's too much on the line
and you don't see them play with freedom
with alacrity risk-taking that you that
you would do if you were playing in a
tournament instead you play small window
chess you you're only playing against
this person you only need to prepare for
them and you make decisions to win the
match not to play them necessarily even
the best moves so far B's in a situation
we've seen that already happen Magnus
didn't win Game one how is that possible
I mean it must have been again at the
tension at the moment he didn't live up
to Robbie's made some slips in terms of
positions that he could have had good
positions and also what the big position
he had in the last game now we're seeing
another decision very practical I just
wanted to
this game thinking about match play
again so we're seeing some stuff that's
strange in terms of what we would see
for them in under normal conditions but
because it's a million dollars on the
line all the prestige in history at
stake they're making other decisions now
at the board so this move yes sir yes
Bishop f3 you don't have to tell yes
you don't tell Bobby I mean everybody
can say what they want you don't have to
sell Fabi that this is not the best move
you don't have to tell him that he's
going to be worse the question in his
mind is how much worse am I can i play
this position easily can you win this
easily are you gonna create all these
chances you sure you're better but are
you going to create all these chances
that are gonna give me trouble or can I
defend this quickly and get to a
position that's gonna be more or less
okay and now we have this on the board
what do you got is this I mean it's it's
optically everybody knows it ain't a
sauce it's not a mystery here in this
studio everybody knows it's better for
white right but this better mean winning
exactly does it mean decisive when I see
these kinds of middle game opposite
color middle game positions Jennifer I'm
forcibly reminded of one great game from
a World Championship match Levon Aronian
quote notwithstanding that was a game
that Anatoly Karpov won against Gary
Kasparov in at Irish defense where there
was a weakness on the g6 square that led
to invasion by Karpov pieces furthermore
what's really intriguing is the world
Women's World Championship match pardon
me the Women's World Championship final
of 2018 where Katya one of vicious Abbas
the colour you Maurice you've pulled it
up for on our screen because you and I
had the same intuition of what we just
saw and it was a brilliant victory
absolutely she won this game Game two
she also had a [ __ ] opposite color
position a position today that she
managed to draw that she should have
lost right so visual opposite color is
it's never just easy and this is a
similar type of position that we have in
the world
championship going on right now in that
there's the for 2/3 majority on this
side of the board this is a three to two
on this side as well I mean it's a
little bit funkier 3 to 2 on this side
but this is a very similar endgame to
well could become something similar to
what we saw in this match and kaca
wanted in style the way she played from
this moment with the white pieces she
played the move g4 would you play g4
like I kind of like wait a minute mmm
this this could get interesting because
it means that it's not going to be an
easy day at the office for black to make
just a quick draw and the game went c5h
for 86 this move you wanted to induce
yessir in your plan but with Queens on
the board and after that a 4 and now a
little a 5 so she's created some action
on the other side and then with the
little threat of g5 which he got to
execute and after 85 ht5 king f7 she got
her weak pawns so she's got the
weaknesses everywhere now to use so
let's start bothering that King oh no
let's switch back to the B line
let's bring the rook up and force a
little defense and then after you've hey
I remember Fabiano doing this to to my
man's ear off in the Olympian start
harassing from multiple sides and the
King goes up threaten this pawn oh no
we're not going to eat any pizza color
ending let's start dancing some more
let's get the rook here and sorry after
this maneuver she had picked off her C
pawn and that won her a pawn very
beautifully done and now free pawn for
her route c6 and now next stop bringing
the king up and then the next stop after
that position this work the right way to
play a six and oh now it became clear
they're gonna be problems Ruki seven
rook b7 not worried about any weak
discovered ideas give me the second pawn
and now it was all she wrote
after this check she won her pawn back
but unfortunately for her this past a
pawn was all that mattered as a7
happened rook a six rookie 7 check King
before rook c8 rook to b7 threatening
rook b8 played it anyway and after
Bishop c6 roughly sings pinning the
bishop to the king beautiful technique
on the part of white in this game to win
that ending now it took her where this
was moved 59 we started when she played
g4 back and move 22 so we're talking 37
moves 37 moves to get it done but it's
not how long it takes is who wins the
race
mm-hmm this is how she got her one point
edge now she was dead lost today handing
in a rook and Bishop versus rook ending
same deal except the way they got there
was even crazier as white should have
won multiple ways we will take a look at
that if we have time a little bit later
but these endings are poisonous we all
know it white is better but we'll
probably be able to defend better in
this game than you engine did in that
one and we see here it's a rook and
Bishop it's mine it's major pieces with
opposite colored bishop on the board now
black's pawn structure is not as bad as
we had it in the jus engine game well
it's very close as four versus three as
you mentioned on the King King side
there was a three versus two in that
particular game here is two versus one
so it's a majority for black on the
Queen side and there is a passer now
what we were doing on our break you and
I Maurice is saying exactly how do you
win it with white and I was saying that
I thought the setup that you want we're
just gonna make some moves so I can just
show you the setup that I want for a
second we were going to do this this
this this so you get the D file
I'm not going to trade all the rugs so
we went something like this I'm really
I'm really trying very hard to and to
induce a move like g6 or h6 and Maurice
you were just saying okay how are you
gonna win if I if I remain passive I
just do nothing with the black pieces I
just remain passive and you get this
whole setup how do I break through its
Zack oh yeah and
I thought okay I've done everything well
I I've tied you down on the light
squares I've got the Queen and Bishop
all set up the pawn hasn't moved your I
don't want to challenge your rook
because I need to keep a rook on the
board
yes so I was thinking that okay we could
maybe get a situation like this I need
to bring my rook into the game and I
thought the way I would do that was to
play rook here and work here now you
actually came up with something even
stronger than I did and it was a it was
a cute move you came up with I think a
setup like this I want to put the King
on g1 because I'm high by first I know
when you went bingo yeah bungo so the
idea is if I play the move h6 black will
play g6 so you said well if I put the
bishop on g6 and then I don't play h6
and you can't take the bishop because
oops that one really hurt and the next
move was h6 so there are ways that black
could find himself in a real pickle and
I'm not recommending going full hog
defensive I don't know exactly what you
know be honest what are you doing if you
put your rook on d7 and did you refute
the whole thing with the burgundies 7
what do you mean like this
no you going that out the whole set of
that whole setup that I was doing I mean
this is rook on h1 keep you going
ok keep going ok - h1 yeah yeah let's go
g6 no King g1 is what I played King g1
ok I'll just I'll just wait for you to
get Z 6 and now rug these seven rook d7
right away ok and now you want me to
take the bishop uh-huh because yeah York
showed yeah we we didn't analyze this in
like the possibility
this but we didn't analyze the
accidental rook being the defense right
on d7 it would have to be timed well
right the rook on d7 it shut down the
idea right I mean it's a bit it's really
a bit far-fetched but the point is your
work on it but if you ever got to h4 in
that position what would happen if my
rook got to h4 in our final position
something like this let's keep our King
on g2 for a second yeah let's do this
and just go rook h4 right well well
you're right just swing the rook to the
e-file that's that's not nice no that
that's that gets serious and actually h6
will get very serious the terrible thing
about this setup yeah is I can't stop
you from getting to e7 at all that's
that's why I'm not a big fan of whole
defense exactly the bishop on b6 has
been a spectator with the fancy 7 you're
right it's not it's not playing any
factor in White's King sight play
somehow you need to get counter play as
black somewhere can we just Jennifer
bring me up to date on the game when we
left it we were just about here were
still here and has have any further
moves been played and our rook d1 no no
so from fabi's point of view he can see
that White's got the the LightSquared
play he wants to play King g2 Queen c2
rook d8 Bishop b4 he can see all of that
now if I'm in fabbi shoes I have to
start to think in a very very concrete
sort of way am I going to be able to
maintain my king side structure as is
yes or no it's a simple yes or no
question if the answer is no then what
is the ideal setup should black
voluntarily play g6 and f5 let me just
make a move on the board to show you and
say look
my Kings is on h8 so it's on a dark
square so you can't do anything untoward
my king now you can play for h4 yeah I
live again right yes okay so what does
it mean and you're gonna you're gonna
have a I've got problems there's no
question i I I have to play very hmm I
don't know how to say it but I have to
play very precisely because I don't want
to fall into a passive position where I
can't do anything and I'm just watching
you and prove right by the way
rook d3 at which moment
this adds absolutely here right right d3
I want a double rooks what what are you
how do you I don't know I think maybe
it's time to play for D 3 d 8 ok I made
this video that means you can play C 5
any time well remember we were playing
Bishop c6 for a reason we wanted to stop
our early iterations of this ending we
were thinking to get the bishop to c6 as
a tempo we were trying to get a temper
against the rope forced the rook away
and then we were setting up with Queen
c2 and Bishop b4 so then it's c5
necessary right they don't know in this
moment you like they'll back back back
all the way back to game position
bobbing a deep think right now the move
of d1 on the board is c5 on tap
necessary at least you can go blockade I
mean I hate my bishop on b6 I mean I
hate my bishop on b6 should I say it
again what a horrible Bishop zombie
cichlid yeah but the C pawn atleast
could be a distracting force so that you
don't just mess around and do whatever
you want least you have to blockade this
thing somehow and if you're on that
diagonal maybe I'm not
worried about you trying to take over
the other diagonal right right and again
the move c5 isn't just you know for
counterplay reasons and things like that
it's just that I think as black you've
got to avoid position where you're just
passively defending at least in this
position
you've got c4 as a distraction but you
also get to challenge the D file in a
very concrete way h4 let's just you know
and once I play this move rook d8 your
only way of keeping winning chances to
maintain the rook on the board like the
Jew and Jun kochia game you take the
rooks off the board I'm thinking blacks
drawn chances go way way way up by the
way Fabi is down an hour an hour on the
clock is not bode well
and again we're up to date for the
current position gen and our on the
clock that's tough the thing is the
thing is when you find yourself in a
position like this and you're gonna
spend the whole day yesterday with your
seconds in meditation yoga whatever you
want to do whatever your practice is
trying to get the bitter taste of the
game eight opportunity lost mmm out of
your system right cuz you know I could
have gone up one
this isn't this was my first real clear
chance to play like a boss and to own
this guy and take a nice little cushion
it's not that big but still
psychologically it's big and the way
you've been playing it would be great
take a nice little cushion and the guy
walks out of there you you swing you
miss by that much and the guy walks out
like whew yeah that's right all his team
is going whoa jubilation you saved that
one amazing the the swing of emotions
the swings the difference differential I
mean [ __ ]
Magnus went out and played soccer yeah
the next day like hey man he got hurt he
even took a picture was that a selfie
because he actually took a picture said
tweet this
I mean he's gotta have a whole different
happy-go-lucky attitude coming into this
round and then he gets the position that
he prepared and then the guy offers him
a clear and clear edge that is a Magnus
type edge I mean this could be a
devastating blow to Fabi in this match
and in and the hard part about it for
him playing this game is the more you
played this game the more you know that
other game is somewhere hiding in the
back going yeah you should have won that
one this is gonna be like a two-point
swing baby this is rough so this is
where the challengers gonna have to dig
deep deep deep to find all his defensive
resources because Magnus is in the
driver's seat big time right now Queen
haven't played yeah in the postgame
press conference I I think that the term
that Magnus actually used as I dodged
the bullet today
yeah although Fabi said because Bobby
was playing the game without obviously
the h2 h3 move obviously without seeing
the computers get super excited yeah
start throwing if yes does he was
impression after the game was like
obviously he slipped but he didn't have
the same impression of the rest of the
world that it was like some horror show
that's just like yeah you know collapse
Magnus defended really well and it seems
like I missed something but it's not
entirely clear where oh that's the
postgame that's right without the press
conference without going to the back
yeah and getting and getting his voice
to say the best human brains yeah so
it's a valid point of view where as
whereas whereas again he just says you
were saying fabbi didn't feel like i
didn't miss something terrible Magnus is
saying I'm really happy to get out of
here whatever else was said that really
here is intuition was going off and
clearly when you sack a pawn and c5 as
Fabi did it's not because you thought
you just had a lot
small little edge that you were nursing
right you could blow the guy off the
board and he missed a couple of moves
and played tepidly with h3 by the way
Queenie fully fully defensive again this
Bishop is controlled I don't even know
what to do with it that this is struggle
where to put let's say you could reap
position it somewhere ladies that's his
intent actually Maurice let's let's
let's make a consequent of c64 why rook
d1 rook d1 rook da for black rook c1
Bishop c5 perhaps and you know as
Jennifer was saying the bishop on b6
looks really lousy you hate the bishop
you ate the bishop
maybe repositioning it to d6 but are you
so happy after all let's say I don't
know King G - Kim G - always seems
useful in such positions right and yeah
because the apon - right that could be
it could be a little snack Gary Kasparov
is gonna be live tomorrow and every day
for the rest of the event he's joining
us for all three years as I said the
reason our break we're going to play all
day
the question is would you rather be
white trying to win our block trying to
draw in both cases that would be like a
win so I'm saying what do you think the
draw I definitely would take white
because the problem is is there's going
to be so much suffering for so long and
there's so many ways of potentially
massaging and I know this is a big
[Music]
waiting game
absolutely I know this is a big I'm not
sitting there suffering forever
yeah it's gonna be a hundred move suffer
and you're gonna blunder yeah
Maurice you should as a wonderful game
that kaca one to take the lead in the
Women's World Championship 2018 finals
of the knockout but there was that game
that Kasparov lost to Anatoly Karpov
into tarish which you know has the same
qualities of this middle game don't know
how easy it is for you to bring that
game up but I think our audience would
really enjoy making that comparison and
why and then Susie astok about Magnus's
chance as objectively speaking this is
really really tough for Fabi and clock
and clock that doesn't make it any
easier when you're way behind on the
clock you feel that that you feel that
pressure that constant awareness that
you have to play very again it precise
from way back Maggie h4 was played I was
about to say for me I I would be most
attracted to the move Bishop c6 because
I want to take away the option even if
it's not necessarily a good move I want
to take away the option of c75 another
move I really like for white is king g2
I think that that just you know playing
on the light squares
you know it's checkers right I have the
light squares you have the dark squares
and I also like this move h4 a lot
because I was trying to get Bishop b4
and Queen c2 battery on the h7 pond and
finally we do have h4 by Magnus and that
was his choice as he's looking if we get
a position like for example once again
yeah if you get a position like this I'm
just putting some moves on the board and
I do apologize if I'm not playing
very
well for either side the idea here is
one more turn talk talk you want to have
a position where you have a pawn on h5
and you're attacking this pawn on at age
7 and you're making it very very
difficult for black to defend and g6 is
just G 6 we'll walk into h5 5 where now
I'm very enthusiastic about bringing my
rib cage for here's the point that I was
trying to recall about the game between
right that was Karpov idea first he
somehow he managed to get the g6 square
weak he then he took over the g6 square
and he set up and he drove Kasparov
sking into the center of the board and
thank you so much Maurice you managed to
ferret out of your seven million game
database over there wasn't a difficult
search we just had to go to the World
Championship match which I knew the game
that you were referring to right and is
indeed a classic was it but it's very
important it's there a limited match and
finally an 84 it was game 31 of that
match and it's important to note though
yessir
86 was played in the opening okay he
didn't do anything to get this move it
was just given to him and that small
weakness and they got to an important
position here right typical I typical
isolated pawn position with the blockade
and it's here where he played the move
Knight a c6 and created that white
square weakness as you see here as he
tried to correct his pawn from pawn a
structural deficit in the middle of the
board but that didn't help him Bishop g4
and I'm gonna jump ahead to later in the
game because the point you were making
eventually he plays this movie for after
setting up efore and then after a couple
of moves he traded off a pair of rooks
and then eventually traded off this pawn
gave the isolated pawn and played this
move Bishop b1 and this is how you
the diagonal talking about yes sir
mm-hmm remember Black has this pawn that
he was trying to work to go down the
board but why had all the light squares
to make black suffer so this is the kind
of position you're reflecting on I avoid
any trades and eventually got this kind
of position and just kept going and you
guys can look it up to see exactly how
white prosecuted the advantage here it's
not that similar to our game terms of
the pawn structure a couple of very
important differences one being that
there's a four to three on this side the
other being that there's isolated pawns
in this game that we're looking at right
now so this is the exact position but
those are the advantages you were
talking about yes sir as the moves were
played h4 was played and g6 setup
stopping the move h5 and a long long and
more long thinks by Fabi and getting to
the situation an hour down on the clock
let me tell you Magnus is very aware of
time as a part of the game it's almost
as though father time is sitting at the
judge board they're watching and going
he was relying solely on his increments
in that game oh no no no I'm saying
Magnus overdid it and tried in terms of
trying to press Fabi on the clock he had
20 minutes and those critical moves
around and he did so I almost like a
park hustler trying to flag you on the
clock breaking news guys breaking news
h5 on the board alert take a look at
that position very quickly that's a
confident move
it's as if Magnus can't slow down so we
do have the move Queen e7 and that's
like okay that's easing the defensive
right h4 h4 and that was a point was
like could should fabby disturb his king
size structure should he just maintain
it or should he voluntarily make this
decision to go g6 in f5 he did play g6
h5 on the board
this is a leave we're now up to date
with the players I'm not sure the
engines like this move like maybe a
little too quickly play little people
only giving a slight edge but seriously
in human terms
I remember seeing a situation like this
I think it was a year mullinski I was
watching and black just captures on a
tribe and this position yeah so what do
you think about this and your long
experience seeing this kind of sort of
is this good for white or is black now
gotten a little opportunity that he's
been able to take this pawn because you
can't control the fourth rank or how do
you control the fourth ranking well
because h4 is gonna happen obviously
when I played the move h5 I want my King
on in g2 so I could play rook h1 right
and you know win back the pawn in the
nicest way when I see h5 coming
prematurely I always look for this
opportunity as black to play g6 takes h5
the decision rests on whether or not
Queen h4 stopping h5h for whether I have
the timing to pick up the h5 pawn what I
mean - this is oh5 has been played so
fabbi is given the opportunity the
question is did he capture that we see
h5 on the board no he doesn't know he
hasn't captured yet he's waiting buddy
huge I mean I remember when I saw you he
did capture look at that the capture did
happen I remember seeing I remember the
first time just as a I wasn't even I am
yet I remember I mean we're going way
back like that and I saw this idea
happen and when I saw I think it was
your Malinsky do it in a game but it's
some grand map you know veteran grant
right we know Alex here Malinsky is a
Hall of Famer and many time participant
in the US Championships but I remember
the the player just taking on h5 like
right what do you think is happening
here I'm just opening up my king I'm
opening up the files around my king
it looks like I'm wrecking my structure
but this is good for me
this idea by
Magnus allowing white not allowing black
without building up his position without
preparing it just allowing black to take
on h5 that seems like a bit of a slip
because this pawn suddenly becomes its
own force in the potential battering ram
and you could have bound the guy first
down tied him up hand and foot that's
the normal sequence right make sure he's
nice and set and you can't move now let
me play the h5 break to play it right
now when the game is still a little bit
dis coordinated for white this Bishop on
b7 is not set where it belongs yet you
have no concrete threats on this side
and suddenly you've offered him the
opportunity to play the move h4 that
seems rash that seems rash and I think
that he's thrown away a big part of his
advantage changing the structure in this
way well let's be very clear memories
Black has lost I mean dead lost after G
takes h5 if white just wins the pawn on
h5 right right just reabsorbed that pawn
on h5 you just wrecked your structure so
actually it becomes a very fierce
strategic battle black really needs to
get in the move h 5 h 4 and if you could
just take me down the primrose path here
for a moment
Queen c4 seems objectively the best move
because white wants to stop h4 and he
wants by king g2 and rook h1 how would
the engine defend blacks position
thereafter it's totally changed the game
now f5 whoa no fear
absolutely no square fear my h4 is
coming anyway regard this this move h5
by Magnus he will come to regret 8 now
h4 no are we so sure that is just okay
so now unfortunately I have to acquiesce
to the trade of Queen no you're not
happy with this well no but at least I
have induced King g7 yeah but isn't this
similar in some ways to the kochia game
with Jew and Jun where she's remember
she managed to get the pawn was it fixed
the pawn on f6 was it
that's game she fixed upon on Essex
here's the pawn on f5 can be this is the
treasure you're talking about right okay
I mean so way different structure f6 is
the weakness in this game F fives the
weakness note single weakness defensible
dual weakness not so much here Y was
able to establish a different situation
where the weakness right here on the
other side of the board as well and
right indefensible so you're single
fixing is nice congratulations
yeah but yeah you're gonna have to
create another weakness because I'm
gonna defend that's the difference
between this ending where there were
more weaknesses in this position than
they were then they are on that chess
board I'm looking at right there that
doesn't seem weak enough for you to what
I mean you know congratulations you got
that but tiny enough if that's the no I
don't think if you if you tell me now in
that position what do I want in the
Armageddon Jin's Armageddon question
switch it back if I if I draw with black
I win no no give me that one now I try
to hold one with the Queen's off
that one's a different one the one that
we just had when I was suffering with
all those pieces on the board yeah oh my
goodness both of us agree we're gonna
make this guy suffered for ever with
white by the way but for him to jump
queen c4 and we're expecting as he knows
h4 is coming out of that five happens
why did he let the change it's I mean
it's like Magnus can't slow down yeah
very reminiscent of Game one where
fabi's time pressure seemed to speed
Magnus up and he aired one of the things
that a you know Magnus is fantastic I
mean awesome in squeezing out these
advantages and turning them into
victories and one of the reasons he's
able to do that so well as it's
extraordinary patience he really does
sit on the opponent and something said
something very strange about this this
quick h4 h5 which he didn't prepare
patiently with king g2 and rook h1 but
he just went for it
Magnus really very rushed by the way
another variation yes other than f5
other than f5 take a look at Luke d1 d1
is a very forcing line yes and now
Bishop takes on e3
No uh-huh seriously let's try it okay so
I was it takes check game G 2 2 now
gauge for now h4 ooh
because Queen takes obviously runs into
Queenie to check getting off the rook
picking off the rook whoa
normally you know you would think even
about the rook sacrifice but in this
case since you've got d5 covered exactly
this would be a winning move Oh God
thank you so h4 so let's take a look
h4 h4 what do you do now engines giving
as only Queen d3 I was about to say rook
t3 allows me a little Queenie to check
action ok and now take on g3 pawn takes
Oh Brittany Queen f2 the trade of Queens
this is another piece for three pawns or
piece for 4 at the moment well of course
you could play a couple of checks but
you have to be careful because rookie to
check picks off your pawn on a tube so
that was very possible as well he played
the move f5 not going into this line
play more logically but that was very
interesting line to explore sacrifice
amazing chance that's just showing you
all the chances that Magnus has allowed
by playing h5 so rashly
and allowing now you see their father
going another another variation by
playing the move f5 that is now on the
board Wow
guys I got great news for us all we have
Peter Lake Oh coming up on the other
side of our break that we're about to
take and the position for fabbi has
improved greatly thanks to music she
takes age five and at five so we'll be
back in just a few minutes and then
we're gonna bring on world chess
championship challenger Peter let go to
get his thoughts on Magnus's edge or
lack thereof
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the st. Louis chest Club to
start a top-tier collegiate chess team
on the very first year of the team's
inception slough obtained second best
University at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University may have heard about st.
Louis's world-class museums art history
science even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by whose
kids it is st. Loup is always exploring
anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage where we have
Magnus Carlsen deadlocked again
Fabiano Cara Juana and this game booked
so promising for Magnus yes but it
really did Jennifer we've had eight
consecutive draws matches tied 4-4
we thought Magnus had a really nice
bishops of opposite color ending right
here and he very prematurely advances H
pomp without any preparation and
furthermore Bishop f3 this seemed to me
his last opportunity of getting any
advantage was to play King g2 played
Bishop f3 allowing this move h4 and I
think that if Abby is going to be really
really happy to get this position but
Jennifer I wanted to say we have a very
special guest all the way from Hungary
grandmaster Peter Peter Lake Oh for me
former World Chess Champion challenger
is on the phone ready to join us welcome
to the show thank you for coming back we
had so much fun with you yesterday
thanks a lot yes hi Jennifer Anne hi
Sarah
thank you so much for agreeing to come
back back to back I know I've been
arresting you but you're most kind yeah
thanks a lot also for the invitation
your impressions of the game so far
Peter yeah well I mean I think the match
is heating up and we can see that in the
second part of the match
first of all in game 8 Fabiano finally
managed to get something out of the
opening quite a promising position and
now in game 9 we see that those
commandos managed to come up with some
idea and this also brings me to the
conclusion or to my thoughts which I had
before that Bobby 12 games is maybe
little bit too short for such a match
because of this modern technology it's
so difficult to finally get a position
with white that you are really looking
for first you have to get the
intelligence from your opponent to see
what he's up to and the only ones you
get all this info
and then you are able to counter it in
the right way and naman was managed to
come up with something that brought him
finally at least some advantage it's not
necessary thanks to the opening but it
was like a new concept and it's always
like a new concept this is the way how
you can disbalance your opponent you can
try to put him in an uncomfortable
situation that he has to make some
difficult strategy decisions over the
board without preparation and when you
feel that your opponent is in the
preparation and he is probably following
his computer preparation then it's very
difficult over the board to decide what
to choose and I think this is what
happened in this game that finally a
Fabiano took on d4 this ext4 move it's
something that usually you don't want
because you you simply release the
tension give by the center and basically
if you already pick on d4 then you are
forced to follow up human vice like he
followed it up by taking on f3 and
taking on d4 but he definitely also
understood that it's no fun and it's
very much Magnus like position that
appeared afterwards with opposite color
bishops with a better pawn structure
with the weaker black king the black
Bishop on b6 is shut out but I I quickly
consulted the engine just so that I'm a
little bit into what computer is
suggesting but I would like to mention
that a computer is misleading here quite
a lot because humanly when you see this
position with the opposite colored
bishops once you have stabilized your
pawn structure you feel like yes black
ones to go g16 g7 trade the rook on d1
and try to change the second rook on d8
and you feel like if black manages to
exchange both rooks then even if your
advantages may be there it might just be
symbolic and black will survive so how
to approach this
in this sense age 46 and magma spraying
age 5 is kind of understandable
I only wonder whether he because he made
this age 5 would quite quickly dip he
missed this f5 idea that Fabi came up
with yeah because after GTA xh5 Quincy
for if black would have not been able to
push f5 idea to go H 5 H 4 then black's
pawn structure would be severly damaged
and the whites push off each for H 5
will be completely justified and that
brought me to to think about what
happens if white would instead of H 5
first prepared this with King G 2 so
let's just come back to this position
yeah if I was hitting g2 now black face
is a problem that if he exchanges on d1
Luke takes d1 Luke takes D 1 the Luke
the 8th which he would like to do then
white can take on v8 Queen takes d8 and
enter with the Queen on f7 which is an
incredibly unpleasant move and now the
king is cut to the corner all kind of
meeting net nets are there and white
will have some h4 h5 breaks so this is
definitely not black once and now we see
that the bishop on physics is completely
out of the game so black is basically
forced to play King g7 before taking on
p1 so it's a strategical position
nevertheless it's all depends on perfect
timing because now black was king g7 now
for example by goes h5 would be very
very logical
now black takes on d1 rook takes d1 and
Luke d8 and I think this is the position
which Magnus had to consider and now the
question is do you exchange the rooks
but you already can't enter to f7 with
the Queen and then you might feel that
yes ok let's just try to take on the a
first
rook rook to the 8th Queen to d8 and
queen e6 I think it's very important to
mention here that why it should keep the
h5 phone because white still has this
idea of h5 h6 and some
which body was black so for example some
f5 queen x6 defense is not possible due
to h6 and those small details can really
be unpleasant to to deal with for black
nevertheless if such a position that if
for example white goes for this line and
black comes up with some very precise
defensive move here then we we are
heavily criticized why that why did he
prematurely changed both rooks
it was clear that he should have kept
them on oh try to play h5 first so it's
not an easy position at all to to decide
over the board and that brings us to
this petition sorry after Luke takes
deewana Duke takes d1 Luke the 8th this
is I think a very important position
Duke takes the one who do you wanna do
create the Luke h1 is a very natural
move exactly it's the ambitious move
however the problem we do catch one that
it allows group D to counter play
another game takes a completely
different character because all of a
sudden black rook is activated however
here white can play h6 check King f8 now
the history pony's hanging there is no
other way than Luke e1 this passive
moved to protecting the pommel is V rook
e1 and this is a position that when you
are able to consult it with a computer
and then computer says you know it's for
the wild you are a little bit passive
but you bought this h6 asset which might
be extremely important in the future and
black has no way of really using his
activity which he has at the moment
which should be quite temporarily then
you understand that this Pony h6 is
quite again however during a gift and
you are supposed to have the initiative
and then you are giving it away for just
to get a cone on h6
it's a very very tough decision so I
don't think that one can blame
players not to not to be able to judge
this properly and it's also not clear
whether this would really he give might
real chances for real advantage but it
felt like the critical way of of playing
lovely insight there Peter into the
position however after the move f5 and
we do have this move Bishop f3h for do
you feel like we do that fabbi has
gotten a reprieve and in fact after the
move h4 he's black into that what we are
calling that drawing window or that
drawing zone that h4 now by black has
gotten him right back into an e equal
position yeah kind of okay completely
equal I'm not sure yet but definitely
aged forest is the problem now what
comes to mind can white played gcg for
maybe computers are just laughing at
this move but I mean over the world it's
one move that you might consider that if
I'm able to play g4 and change the
geophone for the opponent guarantee of
safety for the white king then this is
we have two phones might prove to be
very strong in long terms the double h
pond might not be so effective however
it feels that black shirt is have enough
direct counter play on the g file but if
white is not able to play g f-- g4 and
he is kind of forced to capture on h4
then I do feel like black is very very
close to to equality or at least his
position to defend it's certainly much
easier than it was few moves before yeah
well okay so it really in your your
determination boils down to the salient
question can white play the move g4 and
end up with the two connected passed
pawns of f2 III my first group but my
first concern would be
am i exposing my king from maturely with
the move g4 so let me just ask Maurice
g4 Maurice no dangers for white no
danger no this is fine so your instinct
is correct Peter that g4 is the most
challenging how would you see the game
developing here on after g4 because that
is well basically my feeling is that if
Mongoose has already played the h5 I
somehow cannot really believe that he
missed this F 5h4 idea but on the other
hand I also cannot really believe that
voluntarily from that position deciding
between King g2 and play that that we
already have seen before or analyzed
voluntarily go for this g4 stuff I mean
but but if you are taking on h4 you kind
of feel that you are giving up on an
advantage nevertheless after G's the g4
things might also get out of control for
you I'm very very interested to see how
Magnus will deal with this position now
anything for a baby he's going into a
deep thick here so obviously one of the
youngest said yeah one of his longest
thinks of the game Magnus we've been
mentioning this Peter quite some time
ago already is the fact that the Fabiano
got himself way behind on the clock and
you know in practical play you're always
encouraged when you see your opponent
really taking burning a lot of his time
yeah definitely I mean but this is the
point not easy modern chess to come up
with a new concept because it's obvious
that you can never refute the opponent
of your I mean the opening of your
opponent but try to post some practical
problems which makes him fourth forced
to learn time and this time might be of
really important later on in the game
we have also seen it in Fabiana where
the smugglers in GME that their Magnus
was kind of one hour behind on the clock
however one should also mention one
thing that usually when you are playing
your preparation and you are finally
getting a better position and you know
that probably you are better
however it's far from obvious then it's
very difficult to enter the game with
exactly the same concentration like if
you would be the one who would be slowly
getting this position it's kind of like
getting from zero to hundred with video
car engine it's it's not so simple and
on the other hand the guy who is already
kind of facing the problems for for
quite some time he's very sharp he
understands that he cannot afford to
make just one slight mistake because the
position will get out of control so he
is extremely focused already and
whenever you kind of little bit hesitant
you give the open and the chance who is
having less time but already very
seriously in the game might come up with
some very good defense and and see if
the game this is actually often happens
I wanted to mention this right by the
way a bit to our surprise chagrin
actually we worked XD hey bro take the
position on the board and now it and now
he must play HD for essentially because
Queen say sorry GTH for because Queen's
a sage for black is to smiling happy to
see this in game trades plays rook down
to d2 and suddenly it's black for choice
with all the activity that rook on the
7th f4 can always happen and your f2
pawn will be delicate King is of course
just dancing into the game for black and
so this this is not an acceptable
position for white so he has to play G
takes h4 and going to that line and
that's what we got and we do have rook
takes d8 rook takes d8 as you were just
mentioning g3 takes h4 and when white
played h4 h
five pardon me I'm pretty sure he wasn't
intent on getting this structure I'm
with Peter a hundred percent Peter I
think 94 absolutely Peter Cetera with
you where you were you absolutely
shocked as we were that age five was
played I mean I understand that it's not
it's they're they're different things to
think about but even so did it seem like
it was the kind of position where as
white you'd build and build and milk and
milk and look for your chances as
opposed to just instantly play age five
because concretely if black and get in
takes an age for he's gonna get careful
yeah to be sure to be honest I I felt
like each for each five is justified
only in the case when you spend enough
time and you make sure that among the
choices you finally decided to stick
with it but it felt to me like it each
for each time I'm not 100% sure but was
played quite quickly by Magnus was maybe
it was also kind of the idea to put as
much pressure on phobias as possible
on the other hand also Fabiano might
have already noticed the danger of white
porn getting to h6 so he might have even
just in general conclusion come up with
this decision that he will eliminate
this age age porn if it advances to age
five directly and he has forced in this
F 5h4 idea which maybe Magnus had missed
I mean it's possible you know because
the position looks like it's completely
static black cannot really do anything
white is calling the shots and you might
feel that up to each 5gf xh5 never gonna
work and you just play it and once you
play it you realize that oh my god he
can take and go f5 and then I cannot
stop h4 what I'm gonna do because the
way the game continued by seeing that -
spend a lot of time later on of
capturing on d8 and on h4 it shows that
it was definitely not his intention
exactly Peter one of the things that
really has struck us is this III don't
even know how
describe it it's like when the players
get an advantage something that they can
really chew on like that game eight
we then see a hesitant move in one case
by by a car you wanna where he plays h2
h3 and in like in Game one where Magnus
does not play rook g8 + g3 or eg several
Queens or seven - B - so it's sort of
like when the players are getting
advantages it's almost like they don't
want to spoil it and their caution or
hesitancy throws away the advantage that
they've built up yeah I mean this also
shows how complex chess is I mean
getting your position where you are
happy and you have the advantages on
this level already extremely difficult
to get so finally when you get it you
kind of maybe also relax a little bit
you are too happy that wow you know
finally it worked and and you know just
for a second you relax and and your
advantage is gone it's it's it's
extremely tensed and we should not
forget this is the World Championship
match both players very very much
understand that one victory if they
could get in the lead would make their
life much much more easier it's not the
end it would anyway still be the
beginning but then you know deciding on
openings for someone who is living it's
much easier than you are not anymore
under this pressure of you have to try
to win with white because you have to
try to get real pressure on the opponent
then you can just try to to see what's
happening when someone is behind then he
doesn't have this luxury anymore than he
really feels like every game is decisive
and he has to tries to try to punch back
as quickly as possible so there is a lot
of mind games going on
maybe the players are also a little bit
kind of afraid of meaning because it's
I mean they know how important it is and
you really want it and when you really
want something then you might lose a
little bit the focus of the game you
start thinking about the desert and you
start thinking during the game that you
know how nice it would be because I
actually have no idea what I'm gonna do
in the next game with white and then
it's already not a problem and once you
just little bit get distracted by any
thoughts like that can actually
influence your your next decision at the
board and you just has it you are may be
hesitant or you miss something here in
this case now Magnus was not hesitant at
all he went for h4 h4 h5 maybe it was
too fast
he should have prepared it better it's
you never know when this exact moment to
miss coming in that's another problem
for us it's very easy because we are
following it with the engine and then we
see that the revelation is changing so
that was the critical moment over the
board you don't know that you feel like
you have an advantage so let's nicely
build it up but we are so strong that
whenever they get a little bit of chance
they already kind of defend also the
very very unpleasant positions right
well in this exact position when I see
this move
g3 takes h4 Peter the first thing I
think about is that well now that
White's King is exposed
let me as black put my battery of c5 and
Bishop c7 and queen coming to e5 let me
try to take advantage of the fact that
this pawn on g3 is you know in a sense
exposed or opened up the dark squares
and after I don't know maybe you have
your own thoughts I'm thinking that c5
Bishop e7 bring that passive Bishop
that's been sitting on b6 bothering
nobody
you try to bring it into the game and
force an attack or try to achieve an
attack against
White's position do you see
Magnus as having an advantage here or
what what's your take in the position
you think after g3 takes h4 it's already
too late to speak it of advantages you
had mentioned that you yourself were
looking at g3 g4 as a better potential
yeah I mean okay I I suggested GS b g4
but it's very easy for me to suggest I'm
not sitting there exactly if I would be
sitting there I would definitely have
this idea of playing GC g4 after like
five seconds but maybe I would spend 30
minutes calculating G 3G 4 and finally
saying no no I'm just not liking it okay
let me take on h4 and then the continuum
and that game however what strikes me a
little bit that madness to convey 8 and
took on h4 so I'm trying to find the
reasoning why did he capture on the 8
first right exactly that's did you find
the answer because I didn't either
no but maybe it actually doesn't really
matters because it seems like anyway
might we'll have to trade the rooks but
I mean this idea that you mentioned c5
Bishop c7 is very natural once you see
it I have different idea I was
considering Bishop d6 to c5 and to d6 I
mean that was the move that came to my
came to my mind however when you
suggested c5 which came as a shock to me
because it felt like anti position every
Bishop on b6 to even consider this
movements move c5 but once you get
Bishop c7 and 25 then it's clear that c5
is is also a good move right we've also
looked at your idea of Bishop v6 c5 in
other positions as a way of getting the
Bishop to d6 and on this diagonal
Maurice you had a question
few points to just interject with Peter
as you mentioned you wondered why he
traded
if he took on h4 immediately he did have
a bit of a problem with this idea rook
GA check and you have to be very care
for the move king h1 which looks
entirely natural here suddenly gets met
by this move f4f our changes everything
and suddenly black is winning the game
is over not even funny what's going to
happen because the h4 plan is hanging in
this position and if Queen takes on f4
suddenly rook f8 shows up your Bishop is
hanging the H pawn is hanging that his
rook d f8 the rook you didn't trade off
well DFA chose up hitting the Queen and
the bishop and getting ready to pick off
h4 and we should make a point after f4
if you try to save yourself with Queen
to c3 check suddenly the move rook d4
should have traded that rook off shows
up as well
spectacular move with the problem being
Queens h h4 m8 is on the board so get
rid of that rook so the guy has no
chances whatsoever it looks like that's
why the trade occurred Thank You Maurice
at definitely clears the cobwebs because
it goes to show there is some poison I
mean it makes sense because White's King
has been exposed after g3 takes age 4
which is once again why we see in the
game oops
yeah sorry in the game g3 takes h4 was
played like trying to block on the so
try to block the the production of c4 to
h4 is just not that powerful because as
we play everything for Bishop after king
h1 yeah like rookie for now Jen yeah we
can just take it right exactly yeah and
there's no like great follow up
you're missing a rook yeah you ran out
absolutely no you run out of attacker so
okay so why rook g8 King h1 what was the
idea of rook g8 again a little wow maybe
he just wanted to some tactical lines
later on that easy fun machine job maybe
Queen geez
in fact that is the thematic idea in
this position to be able to play f4 at
some point we saw the tactics show up
there Rock Jeep was one way is one way
of doing it simply rook Jade check and
rook f8 is gonna happen quite shortly we
should point out that instead of rook GT
could have also played Queen e5 the
engine gives this control of diagonal
which looks like a position of move but
also with the very concrete threat of
playing the move f4 and wrecking the
white pawn structure going into an
endgame where those pawns are
indefensible and prizing open this
diagonal prying open this agonal for the
bishop for example if you play a move
like rook to d1 you get that on the
board rook to d1 he could start with
this check King f1 and still play f4
here looking again to open up this game
so no longer takes takes rook f8 you
can't guard the pawn the rooks coming in
there's print is just easy no worries
for black in this position
so this f4 move is the thing it's always
pawn breaks it the position can change
all at once the pawn breaks keep coming
back
what's the pawn break that you need and
the one that black needs now is this f4
move and it will give him real chances
so rook g8 with the idea of pushing the
King away so you can play Rock f8 get
this diagonal in control and always get
this f4 energy going
but Peter before I let you go I have one
more question yesterday you were doubted
us with your thoughts on the special
akov and there was some speculation in
the next game considering five you got
such a big edge on the open Sicilian do
you think magnets will switch back to
double King pawn no I don't think so I
mean the problem of this idea of Fabiano
bead 95 was that I think it's very hard
to repeat also for the white side but
this is already also some mind games
going on you don't know I mean nah
Mongoose team should focus fully on
covering this 95 line or they already
anticipating a new try from Fabi
I mean Fabi steamed it's it's all kind
of very very messy and what I find quite
amusing
looking at these lines that Maurice
showed with f5 f4 and also with the rook
moves on Luke de forbid attacking on h4
it's December's very much of the
sveshnikov Fabiano is having that
position which usually i mean i played
so many slash nichols and i know exactly
that when white was trying to win it was
trying to torture you and them was
trying to win on the queenside
that many times black opened up
something on the Kings side and the dark
square bishop which was supposed to be
the bad Bishop was finally the winning
piece and this deposition with f5 f4 is
exactly based on this concept of opening
up the bishop that's also how I came up
with this Jesus pg4 idea I wanted to get
rid of this F pawn because if I keep the
I mean I've exchanged the f5 phone for
the gee-gees your GF your poem then I
keep my structure intact I mean my pony
f2 and III can only be changed by some
Bishop sacrifice which is with little
material never the case so yes
liturgical speaking this GS d g4 would
be the move to to potentially pose black
problems but it's also kind of a pawn
sacrifice so you you never know when the
black king is anyway feeling safe I mean
black would probably take on g4 put the
Queen on f6 always having contact lay
against the f2 pawn and probably it's
only been nothing very good Peter
we a very important question for our
viewers of course is that yes that you
were in the table tennis tournament the
ping-pong tournament I doesn't see the
trophy behind you what does it mean well
it means actually nothing we we won the
match seven three I played two matches I
won one and the most one so I brought
50% my team members won the match and I
think that's fair because I haven't been
playing for half a year I was just
traveling way too much there was also
brakes and I last had my match in end of
March so I need some some time already
last night I also played so I'm getting
ready for the next challenges but your
team won overall round three very
impressive by a bigger margin and either
players gonna win that match right now
we've seen the move Queen f6 by Fabio
move you mentioned when the f5 pawn was
traded already but now we see the move
Queen f6 with a similar idea
maurices mentioned once black a well
black is actually threatening to play
the move
f5 f4 and thanks to this threat of Queen
takes h4 mate there would be a trade of
Queens and an easy draw this feels like
White's advantage is really melting away
anything that you can see that Magnus
might might might be able to press a
little bit still no I don't think so I
also believe that he should be really
angry with himself right now because I
mean just five six moves ago it was P
that he's in the driving seat and I
think his problem was how to post the
most problems or Fabi and not just few
moves later all his advantages basically
gone I already don't consider this
position to be at all advantageous for
white I mean practice practically
speaking black has all kinds of ideas to
get counter play white also already
should start thinking about safety so
maybe changing changing the rook which
is kind of a silent drew offer might
come in to to Minot because you want to
do it but you just simply don't
understand what you can achieve in this
position a part of you might run into
some trouble if you keep on trying to to
create something from from nothing and
now the white king is clearly already in
more danger than blacks if white is
trying to do something I mean the only
which so-called would make sense is the
move Queen c4 to f4 to blow this f5
bonus what he played and he played Queen
Anne instantly Bishop d6 your favorite
Bishop coming into the game exactly
Bishop c5 sorry up I'm projecting but
yeah I'm hoping to play on the next move
Bishop c5 was played yeah exactly and oh
yeah that's what I saw that Queen f4 is
the only principal move but it's going
to be met by Bishop c5 and I don't
really believe that white can just play
chess and do a bish of these things so
the rook trade with Luke g1 would be
extremely logical enough - Bishop c5
because otherwise white is just running
some risk which he doesn't really want
because if something goes wrong it might
be just completely lost it's not like
you can slowly totally open and exactly
exactly yeah I think that's a very good
thing that you just brought up that for
amateurs as well you said that Magnus
would be angry at himself and we all do
that we all make the mistakes and we
recognize it it kind of after the fact
that oh we just spoiled our advantage
how do you keep calm in such situations
how do you stop beating yourself up and
say okay let me make the practical best
move which is rook g1 when you messed up
your instinct is to beat yourself up but
you can yeah yeah exactly I mean you
have to control yourself and okay now
nothing really tragic illogical thing
happened the match is tied it would be
much more frustrating if you would be
done the point and that would be your
chance to bounce back then you would be
really angry however I think by slowly
getting towards the end of the match at
least of the classical phase because if
it continues like this then we might see
the die breaks but I think there is a
lot of psychological aspect I mean first
of all that prior to this game in the
last three games we have seen Fabiano
getting to times chances one time this
soaked
mathematical we know of the computer
which was okay very difficult or
impossible to find over the world
because you don't know that then you
have to search and what you are
searching for but then he made a very
easy drop in black and in the AIDS game
he managed to put pressure with white
for the first time in the game and
that's why I saw that this game Magnus
will be extremely better mind to show
that you know I'm bouncing back because
I'm not like the latest trend of this
match at the beginning I got a good
position bit white I mean with black in
the first game after ok you kind of
equalize but I was calling the shots in
the first games and then suddenly
towards the six seven eight game it's
the kind of shifted towards Fabiano and
believe me that when you are getting
some unpleasant positions it to defend
them it's you might just say after the
game that yeah it's very nice that I
defended them but during the game you
are losing so much energy and so much
nerves because you are facing this
feeling that what happens if I am losing
of course you have to push it away
because you don't have the luxury with
unpleasant to bad position to think
about anything else than the position
but it's kind of still there in in in
back of your head so I think Magnus was
very pleased that finally in game 9 he
showed that yeah and I'm also able to
come up with idea and I'm putting my
opponent under pressure and once he got
it then letting it slip so easily I
think this this is really frustrating
because it was not kind of a
psychological movement to show that you
know ok it's the last games whenever you
play it black you will be tortured so it
also puts a lot of pressure on the open
hand because in the beginning of the
match everybody was kind of very
comfortable with black so no problems
with white if you don't get anything but
suddenly when you feel like aha maybe
with black I will have some problems
then you really feel like weed right I
have to show something in order to not
to lose the psychological pattern also I
don't want you to lose your thought but
I do want us to get the analysis
in this position because the game is
still going and Bobby's clearly in a lot
of time pressure it's not drawn yet so
let's not let's not wax as though it has
been drawn the move rook g8 was played
probably didn't play the most precise
move by trading here and applying Bishop
d6 still within drawing turns but now
Queen a for threatening the a pawn and
possibly Queen e8 is on the board so
there's a lot of play left in fabi's
time pressure 12 minutes six moves to
make it's not not real time trouble but
definitely you have to make up your mind
how to how to continue in this position
and we have been claiming that the
bishop on d6 is wonderful it's wonderful
for the ideas of of making attacks but
suddenly and after the exchange of the
rook the a pawn is kind of now much more
vulnerable and a passer would would be
of course real havoc the question is
what happens after F 5 F 4 because that
would be a very natural move to make and
I suppose we will have Queen a7 is what
the engines giving just ignoring that
side of the board to take take the pawn
on a 7 and after F take C 3 what this up
rain takes III looks forced queen takes
h4m I'm getting mated on no there's no
Bishop t5 check we need I mean some I
there are some nasty checks coming yeah
which I would prefer to avoid right if
you King gets knocked out of the bunker
there this Bishop d5 check it still
supposed to be equal but it's not human
equal totally comfortable no we don't
like we don't like our King being
molested yes
yeah then there is still life here I was
going to say
because I saw the smoke Queenie 88 check
as disturbing how about just King G 70
the pawn on a seven I'll take the pawn
on h4 and happily trade one for one
yeah it should be because I mean F 5 F 4
is hanging in the air anyway and and if
once your King is out of danger and your
queen can get back to f6
in safety guarding the long diagonal
than this I mean this a pawn takes ages
to to advance and f5 referees
immediately as I was not speaking about
twin takes a 7 Queen takes h4
possibility for a and a 4
yeah a 4 and okay if I gonna do f4 now
your Bishop is blocked on f3 I'm right
you're not impressed but they throw this
it's the runaway a pawn though he still
has to make moves even though he's not
in a severe time pressure but he still
has to make moves 5 in Bishop c5 or you
know there's there's a there's a we take
c7 track but I want to get that bishops
there but Queen c5 you can still play
baby Queen a8 yeah well the game is the
game lives on sharp right now and
especially as you pointed out Maurice
with a
fabien time pressure this is a next
people is gonna be very interesting but
Peter you wanna we want to give you a
big thank you for coming on the show
again and one last question 5 year
Magnus for the whole match well I mean
basically I have so much respect for
both players I'm really hoping for both
of them to him but if one of them we
lose idea feel
set for the losers so I'm not the right
guy to to add this question I'm always
too way too sentimental
in this sense I'm always on the side of
the loser but I think the match the
match is fascinating and the players are
really giving their maximum I mean it's
really extremely fighting chest
I mean maybe when you see the result
that there are way too many of those you
might simply draw their own conclusions
I mean the players are fighting in every
game both of them wants to get the
maximum out of the games just be out
simply too strong and they are putting
up way too much resistance and extremely
good defense very difficult to win the
game but I mean both deserve well I'm
very ribbon 8 - Peter thank you so much
for joining us again Peter let go
Grandmaster we just asked him last night
and he agreed so thank you so much Peter
we appreciate it thank you thank you
oops we have those moves that reality
it's reality we did so we may guess the
way the game's gonna go don't we get f4
immediately correct Queen a7 takes on e3
Queen takes has been played and this is
the game position we're expecting the
move Queen h4 to be played to recover
the pawn and we end this is the change
the double check threat which the king
can sidestep and go to f8 and the
neighbor there checks the king just keep
interesting keeps dancing prancing
getting out of there no danger of
checkmate happening anytime soon
white is under his own bit of duress as
well to watch out for Wow okay that's
quite a surprise for me I hate allowing
my my King getting molested like that a
lot of moves and you also get to move 40
and your King goes closer to the part on
the other side and and it looks like a
symmetrical position it does doesn't it
I mean it's like you flip the board
there is a there's a mirror going on
here this is exactly - and ASA a2 and h7
yeah and the bishops and the very
interesting position to be usually the
King on on b8 to complete the whole
picture the mirror reverse image if you
will
yep fascinating Wow okay but that one
looks equal
that one looks fine for black and so
he's here he just has to establish that
Queen taste on h4 doesn't land him in
any deep water but if he does play it
then we will have what looks like
another draw in this match because it's
just way too close for blunders to
happen and he's got enough time now
there's a lot of Gibby moves
keep checking me please there's a lot of
free moves I get so I can get to that
time control so we are looking at this
potential position after the checks and
it'll be moved 39 and when King f1 gets
played after all those checks right
he'll have a couple more moves to make
with a lot of time on his clock will
black and really no danger of losing any
more in this very close ending the a par
looks like it could be some possible
pressure but and he has captured on h4
that has indeed occurred in the game
we're here this position looking like
air oh if Queen c3 and Bishop d5 doesn't
produce some material advantage right
away
drop it I mean it's just dead dead zero
zero zero by the way at least they can
claim the record that's what I'm saying
I think Kasparov and Anand will be happy
to give up this record that'll be coming
on the show yeah cuz they hate being
told or being cited every time well One
World Championship match started with 8
draws then it was Gary and Vichy 8 games
of futility and what we call that these
guys don't want to fight at all
by the way that was
not a match that was it that was a 20
gamer so and not a short match not
feeling out period it was really some
exercise in futility and they know it
they don't care of course the next game
an on one in style right a game after
that Gary borrowing the favor
preparation was unbelievable than two
games later the dragon showed up and
just blew poor vichy off the board after
he actually turned to draw down and
blundered in that game that's right and
then again he got hit in another one so
that one will now be laid to rest
no one's about number two this one nine
straight draws and it's not because they
were feeling each other out guys listen
let's be very clear
Game one we could have not even had any
records exactly Game one by done you're
finished right that would have happened
Fabi in game eight yep could have could
have put real pressure on Magnus this
one
Magnus could have put some pressure on
his opponent as well although who knows
the Fabi for guessing right because he
did get this out of Bishop takes f3 when
everybody was saying oh no no this is
terrible for black by the way m84 was
played in queen essex by Fabi
so queen c3 check and Bishop deep red
lines that led nowhere
have been replaced by a four and why is
that a good move what's the diff I can't
take the pawn or can i I always have to
ask the question you could why can't I
take the pawn now this looks dangerous
but actually you survive I mean well I
took one rook pawn already in this case
the H pawn why can I take another one
because there's no Bishop c6 made after
Queen of six right this is the whole
point this would be a wonderful and very
thematic checkmate
except for one small problem the bishop
exactly but poppy did not take the bomb
he did not take the pawn he played Queen
f6 he just he played it close to
the vast and played Queen f6 Queen takes
was a draw
Queen takes a for was a draw on lightbox
done if you're playing unless you're
playing for a win with Queen f6 Queen a
for the games there's no where anywhere
to stop to do anything so now we have to
wonder did he see that it was what was
equal or did he did he ghost and think
there was some danger here well bye-bye
dead and done you mean just take the
perpetual check kind of thing with Queen
H well you do that you just you just
play check and take your pawn right like
this yeah it won't matter right that's
it and that's it that's the end Queen
can come back the yay
well that is perplexing oh I mean that's
just you could just taken upon and drawn
right instead he preferred the move
Queen f6 and obviously Magnus plate is a
pawn because he wants to move it all the
way up the board and eventually it's a
girl and and that this hopefully he
doesn't lose his skating because that's
how not to not just I mean just Queen
moves pawn and we were saying he had a
lot of time on the clock but it's not
that much time on the clock the more
pressure on you the less time you feel
like you have and Queen 84 was just a
draw done now this move Queen f6 there
is a little bit of a move a little bit
it's a ghost of a chance
Bishop to d1 keep the pawn I don't keep
the protect over we try to get this pawn
down the board just a little right not
real it's the it's it's not real but
it's but it's there and Magnus would
look to see whether or not he can keep
something going in this position it's
still equal but it's not dead yes dad
equal as was Queen takes a greeting for
was just dead soon signed the score
sheets that's right so Bishop d1 played
was it played yeah oh so he's dead oh
you know you don't like to give this guy
any hope
just any little I mean why okay but how
how serious I mean okay I do respect
that you have the most dangerous pawn in
the position but how serious is it
really Maurice have to say Queen e5 by
anything really yeah I'm just
I just wanna you know establish my
Bishop on the c5 square so that I've at
least stopped the pawn from ever
marching beyond a6 and I believe that is
what he played Queenie five you're not
gonna trick Bobby in this position no no
I mean the chances were when the rooks
were on the board and if I may ask you
to do that Maurice if you could takes SA
and go back to that position where Peter
Lake Oh said g3 g4
you can't do that what Cecily you don't
control it's busy analyzing this mission
and its job is to analyze Magnus's
current chess position at all this is
not yours you don't get to take it over
I do whatever you want with it
except maybe analyze future lines but
not previous game it's it's stuck here
right now so okay well then we'll have
to use our our own stock fish Peter had
me before was it serious at all it was
not no it was not serious it was I
thought it was the most challenging it
was definitely a move to play but the
engines definitely were not that
impressed by the energy of traded Queens
what Queens and they were move 39 as it
has happened we would expect a draw to
be agreed in that case a5 what else
you've got to get your pawn up the board
Bishop to d4 a6 what else and they're
going to agree to a draw well okay
so let's say white is trying to win it
how fast his only chance is to is to
bolt for the Queen side but I have my H
pawn sir so I can even give you that you
have a lot of obstacles in your way
I have a C pawn I have an H pawn I'm
gonna I could sack my bishop I'm just
letting you understand what I believe
you're drawing I'm just saying okay 40
by the way I would 85 after a five a six
so what are you gonna do something
King g7 good turn King here King g6
good turn by the way I have an f2 pot in
the position I have to keep that guy
under control - mm-hmm I'm gonna give up
any winning attempts this is no I just
point it out you gotta first have to
play f3
well yeah well you're gonna you're gonna
make some tempo move before you send
your King over let's just show the
audience of h5 so now can you - no I
can't probably play h4 and wake you up
now yeah soon I wanted to give you your
chance to win my bishop but it's really
good I mean this guy I mean just as my
bishop gets tied up White's Bishop is
gonna get tied up as well and yeah no
problem no nichijou ja nietzsche
Jennifer that would mean a new worlds
record
a futility games in a row which means
with that the the pressures just been
amped up now no one can lose well now
it's too late
oh the only games to play
you can't go wild anymore sweaty palms
sweaty palms Raheem every single here's
this did this is the nasty Fast Pass oh
this this fast fact is still in effect
yeah let's get this real this fast fact
is still in effect it says in all the
World Chess Championship match
in history seven I've been tied after
eight games and the chant prevailed at
all this doesn't mean that you know it's
tied after nine we'll have to see how
many the chant prevailed
after tied after nine but doesn't change
anything this fact is still quite
relevant absolutely well as you were
mentioning not so many world champions
in the history of the game why because
they didn't lose all that often to their
channel and they won all those remain so
an amazing fast back there about these
World Championship matches in the
history because this game does look like
it's going to go no no no it's not what
we do have in fact let me just refresh
my board I'm going to go to the Women's
World Championship match game and then
recall and by the way the play as
expected Magnus having some fun pushing
his a pawn up to seven by the way let's
spend a little time - the time comes to
review the we want to see this and make
sure we call this but when the time
comes after this game I would stick
around because we're gonna go over the
game that was played today in the
Women's World Championship match oh my
god what a game like you wouldn't
believe
that game was on real also ended in a
draw
where White had win after win after win
in a crazy position we're gonna take a
look at that after this is over because
it is worth the viewing so stick around
for that but in the meantime we'll see
how this game will wait until this game
King s except for all on the board well
I have to admire Joo and June using the
Sarah Juan attack in the King's Indian
when she needs to bring out the wind she
brings out the great ideas alright now
the pressures on as tomorrow she will
have black and must-win situation as
she's trailing in the match by a point
she needed to win today she
really got it boy Oh close some
beautiful moves
oh sweet game beautiful game we will
review that one Bishop e6 played Bishop
d6 on the board as we see there - one
for Katarina Llano just needing a draw
with white tomorrow
that is 5:00 a.m. central 6:00 a.m. if
you get up early so you gotta get up and
watch that one because these ladies have
by the way I've been out some of the
time I get up I wonder your schedule in
advance should Kate win this would be a
break and one has been pretty much a
domination by the Chinese ladies recent
year in recent years they are the ones
who have been keeping the Women's World
Championship title in China and so far a
lot of our Russian fans and for the
Russian players a lot of them are really
hoping that Kate and it will be her
first Women's World Championship title
she was in the semi-finals with three
other players all three other players
had won the Women's World Championship
and she was the only one who hadn't so
some irony going on there and showed a
heart though in her match against poker
Nina which i watch basically from start
to finish I couldn't that one was just
so unbelievable I could not understand
how one was a hit and then hit back and
then boom again we were like oh my god
it was just knocked down get back up not
the other person down what a fight that
was and then she has to win the
Armageddon game and that wasn't a deep
into an end game as well she showed so
much heart when you saw how much she
fought in that one you knew there was a
champions heart beating in that chest
and now she's showing it because Jo and
June cruised to the final absolutely
cruz two games minimum she won to a know
that you win one and a half one
when I have just easy walls no tie
breaks any day at all and got here and
then had to face this determined lady
and indeed she could have wanted a Jew
in gender but she did not find it in
herself to find those brilliant moves
that would have knocked out her
challenger and now she's on the
precipice of disaster he's about to lose
her title absolutely
okay we do have one more move king of
three has been played we're in this
bishops of opposite color ending one of
the one of the ways that you might think
you want to win is to bring your king
all the way over to this son whoops
I did something wrong I apologize I
don't have to get a refresh over to you
Maurice you know you know Lord I want to
tell you it's funny when I was looking
at it I wanted to say that my mind cause
that to disappear right over there I'm
thinking yes sir
what do you analyze like yeah this is so
draw I understood that you it was like
don't look at that please this is just
drawn your just our audience knows it
everybody knows it
we're just waiting for these guys to
finish this up right there's no analysis
needed for this position it's over it's
dead and you're looking at this this
game position now I had updated my board
and maybe something bad will happen to
my board as well because I mean yeah
this is a drum this is a draw the issue
that's interesting about this now is
given how Fabi felt after game 8 giving
out he felt during this game during how
Magnus felt after gave me and now how he
feels with this result
talk about swings the vicissitudes of
the the World Championship match first
you feel happy you're your guy feels
depressed now it's flipped I mean it's
all to me this whole match has been
psychological the whole thing just feels
like it's not about the moves they've
got to win after win well ok let me know
overstate that but they've been a couple
of real opportunities to win three we
can count clear opportunities to at
least put pressure on your opponent in
heavy ways and they have not been able
to do it is but it's almost like the
respect is translating onto the table
itself like from from here I respect
this guy it's happening on the board as
well and neither side able to land a
punch every win now filled with tension
we now after this game we'll have a
three game match it's Zach with
tiebreaks to follow that's what we have
in fact with this game we had what the
ladies had a four game match with
tiebreaks right right that's exactly
what they had and now we have a leader
now we're gonna go down to a three game
match with tiebreaks Carolina might be
happy that he's got to white so white
side of the three game yeah absolutely
including the last round huge now I had
a conversation we were dinner and we
were with a with a group not real chess
players but enough of chess players that
steward actually was the gentleman who
asked me a very salient question he's
saying if Faby felt himself to be the
real underdog in the tiebreak should he
go all out in game 12 how do you go out
we've had callers ask that question is
valid question number one should he go
all out
I guess put it all on the line I mean I
in the reply to the caller eyes I said
you know I think and like an on-set I
think that the the edge from Magnus
might be a little bit overstated by a
lot of media so I think you know he has
to be careful not to give himself more
more risks than edge so it would be
tolerable if he thinks he's a 5%
underdog maybe or 10% underdog and that
high break it would be tolerable to give
a to give a five or ten point negative
in the in the game for instance what I'm
saying is forty five percent chance to
win fifty five percent chance to lose
right that would be good right if you
think that it's around sixty forty in
the tiebreak right so you think maybe
it's time to ramp up the risk in game 12
what is risk you know when I back up
back up
what does risk me huh how do you risk
that game what is that what what does
form does that take is it a gambit
knowing what is it know what does it
mean how do you take a risk
Oh
so let's imagine that okay from the
first from the start here's the way I
would interpret what I'm about to say
so here's Fabiano we're in game 12 Bobby
has to win to avoid the tiebreak that
we're all afraid of it
so poison others he sees efore see five
by Magnus he sees night of threes he's
96 so already instead of this Russell
emo which has been lame and brought him
nothing he has risk and risk or he is he
has gone for an open Sicilian with a
special cough now after the move e5
Knight here d6 we saw in the first
fashion account that he went Knight d5
and tried to control the complicated
lines of the special cop here's what I
mean by risking Bishop g5 is a
double-edged move that could easily lose
the game just as well as win the game
but Bishop g5 is where you have to go is
what you've got to do to play for a win
and I don't think Knight d5 is the right
play but the lines here yes generally
just lead to a draw risk from tomorrow
which I think it's a toss-up I still
think I still have an instinct urgency
devil king upon tomorrow Peter thinks
we're gonna have another Sicilian right
but I think in the last round no way
Magnus is going double king von okay
here's another example of what I mean by
risk okay
Fabiano as black has been playing a
Queens gambit declined and a couple of
games have featured this move Bishop f4
and c5 and for example the players have
reached this position and I thought
after Queen 8592 Fabiano played the
retreating move Queen on a5 to d8 matte
and in this position Magnus
played 93 Bishop d6 yeah so I felt that
Magnus had three ways of trying to play
for an edge rook d1 Bishop g5 and
finally castles Magnus chose a fourth
way which was Bishop e2 risk-free got
nothing fabbi drew I'm saying you got a
castle if you're fabbi even the rules
are reverse you're gonna try to play for
a win right you got again again what you
just said was the most chap you said
except a risk the most challenging but
yes sir that's not a castles in that
game I hate I get what you're trying to
go with this but I'm gonna challenge
your example
okay in that game he didn't castle
because Bishop e6 was a novelty by black
and he said he must have looked at
castles I don't know that I want to go
for his preparation right so in the case
of fab' if he were in the same setting
he might say do I go for the most
testing move because I've walked into
the guys preparation that seems
different from I'm in control
do I go into my main preparation or in
preparation that I think is risky like
you said I'm saying because in that
situation here's the choice because you
don't you you don't you don't really
know what the guy's got prepared so you
could back down but if he's in control
easing you think you're saying how do
you play in risky fashion like Jenna's
asking he 45 how do you play in risky
fashion against a 45 what does that
entail and Evans gambit no right is that
now that actually is a risk I mean kind
of like a risk a king's gambit right
that's that's called being risky be 45
Lissa's but buddy no that's not what I'm
saying
no what I'm saying is you take the most
challenging situation like castles in
this setup that I have
like Bishop g5 against the subversion of
[ __ ] if I go efore Magnus goes 'if I've
and he plays a Zaitsev I'm playing a
four game like you're playing the main
yeah absolutely
and I'm not worried about your
preparation preparations too late
I mean it's now yeah and I won't even
boy I would even see that as a risk I'd
be jumping up and down the guy played
the Zaitsev arresting Carl right in this
kind of position and I got the white
pieces and I prepared yeah so that's
where I think we're going on the other
hand like you say Jan how big big a dog
is Faby in these they're rapid in blitz
ratings is that will tell you quickly
remove it look at that rapid difference
almost a hundred rating points and look
at blitz
oh my argument starts to fall apart with
the Blitz but for game Robin Matz that's
serious yeah rating point difference 91
and the King yeah whoo this is not a guy
you want to see in rapid and definitely
not in blitz the difference is so qgs
number one look at the number one in the
world on the inside I went over the
differences though I see and you know
Annan said it's so beautiful that if you
put Carlson against the best players in
the world and wrap it in boys and Fabi
no question and Magnussen's gonna have a
much better school in the tournament
yeah but match is a little different
because we're not only playing men over
at all we're also playing all the
preparation from the back that's it and
like I said if Bobby gets one of his
jams like yesterday's or two days ago
you know in a wrapping camo boy he could
he could just you know but but I see
people like noch amol in your mp3
three on move one in blitz no you know
say let's change up your preparation do
you think that Magnus really cares about
prep Magnus will avoid prep at all costs
because his flow is so good right his
flow that's all it's about
his flow is so fantastic they just gonna
say no no we will play any position it
won't be one of those things and I'll
avoid all that preparation stuff and go
into my strengths which is just play the
game play the game play the game play
the game and that's what he's gonna go
after so I get you I get you but we were
talking Magnus Carlsen let us just be
real you can do any assessing you want
and any rationalizing it will be a David
versus Goliath battle faces against
Magnus and okay I know the David story
ended pretty good for David but not only
does magnets have Goliath Goliath wife
will show up he's got he's got kids are
gonna get upset there's a lot of bad
things that could happen to you if you
play this man and wrap it in blitz and
it will be written not as oh you know
what they were kind of close anyway
Fabi won the match it will be written as
an epic upset if he takes down Magnus in
the tiebreak which would be a great
story I mean obviously I'll faint not
for the Norwegians enough for Magnus no
but for the world at large to see this
take down would be an epic story that's
right and that's what we will have to
call it as not as well they're kind of
close in the world in rapid in number 18
in blitz come on Jeb that's pretty bad
sorry and there is the diaper that's
true where he's still number one we got
two lights for Fabien yes one way one
way for Magnus including tomorrow
Thanksgiving
yes today yeah that's right we're we got
Bobby with the white pieces it's gonna
be really interesting to see how that
opening goes yeah yes
has everybody in the United States will
be cooking one eye on the turkey one eye
on the chest TV absolutely and well I
just got to ask you yeah you you
expecting an opening open Sicilian
special knock off or do you think that
Magnus will say enough is enough I'm
returning to e4 e5 and my bread and
butter I'm predicting double king bond
double king pot and how about yourself
Maurice I hate predicting nobody don't
you love it but no not openings
because obviously he prepared he's got
his first line he's got his a five line
and he's got something else right right
there just in case something else and so
what is the state of mind going into
this next game tomorrow
that's important because walking out of
today he might feel like this nonsense
happen up in here man I I gotta get this
out of my system and let me not fight in
the next game let me just play my solid
stuff and get out of here with a drum
what or will he say nah let's just keep
going at him you know forget about today
that's to me where the state of mind I
can guess that and I I just feel like
he's gonna feel disappointment today
there's no plane of course I mean we
meet of course they're still planning to
to the point they're about to agree a
draw though yeah but I mean they just
been moving and moving and you know they
could have drawn a long time ago
which to me suggests that Fabi is
deciding he's not gonna offer a draw
because he's what slightly worse yeah
he's really not but but Magnus is saying
I'm not offering a draw either like
Magnus is maybe a little bit he's right
now wait
yeah I know it's a drawing so I keep
trying I'm with Jen I think Magnus
really did have it's that game
the open special [ __ ] scared the bejesus
out of him I really think he's thought
oh my god you know he's having too much
fun I am NOT giving him I'm not gonna
get my opponent that opportunity again I
think he he goes back into his usual
habitual shell of a double King pawn
defense and says I'll shut down the
match till the tide breaks that would be
the plan whether it's successful or not
we will have to see yes yes and a brayer
or one of the many defenses that Magnus
can hide behind but I mean not a
sharpest no yeah and the question is how
do you amp it up are the risk factor for
white when your opponent is playing a
closed rule elope as I mean you can talk
about the Spanish torture or you want
but it's just you know just little
advantages here and over there and not
big attacking opportunities and by the
way I just got a news that is finally
over and what was the result
Karlsson Cara wanna neither man could
get the better of the other one so far
lots of better positions but no blood
absolutely except with the football game
well Peter lake oh you just said it so
well himself so these guys are too good
they're just not making mistakes and
that the drawing zone is just too big
they are making mistake yeah yeah you
know it is hard
chess is hard that's what Peter said
yeah chess is hard yes they're making
mistakes but if you don't find the right
way they'll come back like that right
that's the problem I'm making a mistake
you better knock me out because you
don't play them knockout blows then I'm
defending and defending and defending
and I'll find a way and then suddenly
your chances are
and that's what we're seeing because
game one the Bobby was dead
yeah completely game eight Magnus was in
deep trouble right a couple of moves and
he would have been on the back foot
crying right this game nice advantage
not winning but by no means but to give
the guy an easy recipe with h5 just an
easy recipe in this game where we're
talking about right here just no
patience just playing h5 quickly just
like that and then just give a recipe of
takes and f5 and h4 and suddenly three
moves let just took three moves
you played age 5 and then three moves
later you're going where's my advantage
what happened I was supposed to have
something here so they're not playing
perfectly but what's happening is when
the mistakes are made the that precise
chest you've got to play you know you
mentioned this earlier and of course
this it's a different tension to this
match but you mentioned if Karpov had
this position oh yeah I'm gonna suffer
for so long right it's not even funny
give this to Carlson I think in a
tournament game the second round of
Norway chess you're the Milka you're
gonna suffer or a sink he'll come you're
gonna suffer and suffer he's gonna relax
it's gonna be cool the fact that he
played quickly here it's all about the
psychology right now these two can't
they're at each other's heads and it's
like they they're there in lockstep
some something about them being so equal
has created this situation and even when
you have a big advantage it's being
frittered away Thank You Maurice we we
have three more games left but we have a
all-star guest lineup for those coming
on every day we have the xi'an on and we
have a lot of me or emic but another
exciting schedule of guest note that
there is a rest day in between
it's game going forward right so we've
got Thanksgiving tomorrow and we've got
to rest a game arrest in a game so the
preparation and stuff even further as we
reach the finish line but Maurice
actually has an update on today's
Women's World Championships luck facts
oh yeah oh my goodness and yes indeed
these ladies are playing like champions
going all out for the wins and we see
that count arena like no one game to to
take the lead and it was Anjou engine to
try to win today and I'd like you guys
to take commentary as well because this
was so much fun to think about this
particular game yeah so you talk about
this system let's go here Bishop d3 when
I saw it I thought yeah so Sarah won
yeah
one of your favorite systems tell us
about this line and where do you think
things diverged in this position here
well for sure you and June it was in a
situation where talked about needing
risk she has to win with white so she
plays the system with the Bishop g5 move
and what she did is she followed up with
a pawn sacrifice this move Knight takes
d5 as a pawn sacrifice if she recaptures
with a pawn c4 takes d5 she would find
herself in a benoni style position but
the Knight takes d5 g5 bishop g3 takes
takes
she's clearly saying to her opponent
take my pawn which is what happened in
the game pawn number one your rooks
hanging route b1 looks like auto uh-uh
h4 sacrificing an exchange in that
position and her opponent the Caterina
said you know what cheep-cheep rook so
she played g4 in that position was keep
following it on your board rook b1
Bishop g7 and now castles just a
straight pawn but a lot of weaknesses on
that side where that King is so that
gives white compensation how much we
don't know rookie
Knight f4 and then all of a sudden c4
with no development this one looked
really dynamically scary like you're
you're not developed at all playing
moves like this opening up the position
opening up position I don't believe in
this kind of play is obtainable on c4
rook to e4 Bishop back to the e3 and now
if this move rookie five and this is
where white said okay you know what all
my pieces are good you still have a lack
in development the rules say open up the
position if you're gonna win the game
let's go
f3 masterful move in this moment h5
trying to hold the position down Bishop
back to e2 not an easy retreating move
but she's trying to break down that g4
point and her opponent defended now with
the move Queen to d7 engines in like
this move they felt like you know what
that side has to defend itself in this
position but it's still in fact good for
white here anyway but Queen d7 made it
worse after this move Queen d7 she
played rook before and this is where she
missed a juicy chance folks she could
have taken on g4 here and the line is so
clear and so forcing see this rook okay
so this rook is under control of the
bishop and there's an interference move
here gen that just begs to be played
check this out this rook on f1 the
dynamic play that would've been and it
looks like hey why can't I just take it
and then after you take my rook play
pawn takes on e5 at minimum right that
way I do pieces for two piece of it or
give it up give it up but Bishop g4 and
suddenly the e6 pawn is hanging you
can't play Queen takes d5 in this
analysis because of Queen takes Queen
and let's finish that line yes we takes
pawn takes and then Bishop takes on c8
winning a piece waiting up and dropping
this Beulah you're losing a rook in the
corner
at least another piece when your Knight
moves Bishop takes b7 is gonna happen so
that was that would have been a body
blow
96 would have been tremendous in this
position not played but not played
instead rook before was played and not a
bad move but the tempo lost and then and
now Knight a6 rookie four very important
moment now Knight c5 and I will tell you
I was getting ready while I was watching
this I was getting ready for this
broadcast yeah and when nicely five came
on the board I stopped and I said okay
what am I gonna play here that pawns
hanging I don't want to give it up
Bishop d3 Queen c2 ideas do I take on h5
etc and as I'm busy working it out and
trying to iron my my clothes
she dropped D five on the board that's a
boss what and you know there was a part
of me that wanted to play e5 but I said
nah that's not gonna work
when it happened I said is she for real
and then I started looking at and said
whoa we got a player in the building
85 what a move you could play two
captures she took with a pawn if you
play Bishop takes on e5 then Knight
takes h5 and you can't take on g3
because the knight of six for coming
quickly your Bishop can't leave and so
you don't have to back up with the
Bishop hightail it out of there and
suddenly White is taking over the game
in that line with your Bishop mired in
the corner you still haven't developed
anything yet it looks ratty in this
position even frankly nine if six might
be considered so II five was a beasty
move and now D takes e5 and Knight takes
on h5 suddenly the bishop is stuck and
you want to take it and when the e pawn
now in this position playing ninety four
and she had to find a movie as that both
of us were so sweet so deep so sweet
again this so instructive [ __ ] found
this move the move d6 very nice
g6 the pawn is basically invulnerable
you cannot capture this pawn either with
the queen or with the night because at
the end of the day there's knight g7 and
Bishop takes let's take a look at that
let's take a look
take the pond oh boy then Bishop c4 is
showing up and with the combination of
rook on f1 and the bishop on c4 hitting
f7 you're going down you are so I think
we decided the best move was Queen e6
well let's just do a variation sugar
fans can see it okay if Queen takes
these six that's easy that's crazy
Knight takes and Knight takes g7 King
takes g7 oops and that's a piece and
buys and that's alright I match and if
you go well I'm gonna attack your Bishop
at attack your knight
yeah but I'm gonna retreat you defend
both divert my piece up as well also
Bishop e5 look possible also possible
and if you do it the other way which was
Knight takes d6 I think it's still night
take same problem same problem might
takes one g7 and this is a5 check and
you're winning right so that was why we
felt that d6 which was a sweet sweet
move wasn't us by Xu wen Jun she
retreated a bishop and much like the
Magnus and fab e1 hesitant move that
Bishop just gave Kate just the timing
she needed to get in this defensive move
f5 oh sorry yes it was long line that we
need to point out okay as well that was
really 66 and you mentioned Queen e6
this is where it was really hard Queen
e6
yeah and now the best idea this is crazy
chess
Bishop c2 Bishop d3 Bishop d3 ship d3
and then after Knight takes D six Bishop
c2 two pawns down in this position but
the lead in development is clear all
five of White's pieces are ready to
pounce blacks pieces are completely
discord innate 'add and undeveloped and
Bishop b3 is coming and Murder She Wrote
is gonna be on this board right this is
tremendous double pawn sack to open up
the lines and crush your opponent this
would have just been a pearl off a game
for the world champion should just as
Kasparov and I both said if fabbi had
won that game
when Bishop h4 they would be scanning
his body for microchips
this is sacrifice scan instead she
played very logically with the move
Bishop to e1 so let's get back to the
board position F where she played Bishop
p1 an f5 that really changed the game
quite a bit and now she played nice h d7
King takes and the game continued with
over oh no not at all
now we're getting very close folks to
that opposite color rook and Bishop
ending where have we seen this one maybe
today here we go in this dynamic
position the bishop found itself on d3
here comes our the Queen trade suggested
and then just a couple moves there it is
now we have rook and Bishop versus
working bishop which they had yesterday
but both sides have passed pawns yes and
it got crazy and it should have been
equal but look at this look at all these
past pawns on the board right company
Passport there's at least three and
another one coming in the bleep are you
gonna happen for passed pawns exactly so
when we came in our studio the players
that actually reach this ending and we
were what is going on we weren't sure
and right here came the crucial I think
this was the key moment very big mistake
very big mistake you have to play King
c4 first there's not the move III
correct c4 was required to save her
people on then it was still tricky but
black would have held black was still
okay and the whites bananas III gave
white just the moment she needed to win
the game and she started well yes here
and this is now comes the the slip King
G - no Kim G - is brilliant
no sorry he was brilliant it's right
here this is the superb really played
before Jack and that let our opponent
off the hook smooth remind you found
yeah I am always looking for those
active moves rook belong behind passed
pawns and in this case it's a skier that
was why I was so attractive and the
beautiful thing here is if the continue
about getting the rook behind the past
pawn you know we get we have tactics
around that and chess right but check it
out he could have in this position she
could have played II won nights with
right going up a piece but after king f2
now it's all about White's as pawns and
blacks main dangers are gone and these
pawns are just way too fast
going down the board should be five
coming but this is such an easy slip to
make I mean it looks really logical
because after all your King takes over
the defense of duty and look at this
just perfect rook e1
Bishop back yeah yeah threatening e1 and
now you got it you got it
lock with the rope cause you've got with
the rook what a phenomenal game and then
finish with the bishops Wow
and by the way what was that what
happened today this this is very similar
miserable opposite colors and again is
how it ended both world championship
games ended with the bishops of opposite
colors and then the same day and this
was a perfect blockade so we'll all be
watching as tomorrow is the final game
and you went you need government to to
tie the score what what a game the
commentators must have had fun with that
one I think I saw somewhere that
Castagna can more as Emmett for
commenting on the game so that takes
also a lot of heart by the way Alexander
Christine you having been eliminated in
the semis going into the booth to do
commentary
well her friends the match is being
hosted the tournament is being hosted in
Russia of course and the Russian crowd
I'm sure just soso behind Kate just as
we are with fabbi
but
that's an exciting match I didn't see
the coming because Joo and June had
played such an extraordinarily efficient
tournament I mean she looked like she
was just cruising to her title there was
an extra day off before the final which
I mean a lot which helped Catarina no
doubt along great she played 21 games
yeah and then they got one day off and
they started playing again and Catarina
is playing phenomenally worthy challenge
whoever wins that will be as worthy
absolutely absolutely worthy champion
well tune in tomorrow we're gonna have
not only Women's World Championship
starting in the morning which we're
definitely gonna be talking about we got
a star lineup including the one and only
garry kasparov who's gonna be taking a
little break from his bank and
thanksgiving prep to give us his
thoughts on fabi's fraps as well I want
to only be tomorrow we've got we've got
Gary and Vichy and William what a way to
celebrate Thanksgiving yeah that looked
like a lot of goats three goats
Bobby four and a half of Magnus
attention just keeps ramping up
Thanksgiving how could you not spend it
with magnus carlsen Fabiano Cara wanna
the three of us and also Gary Kasparov
Indiana and I just got to keep her name
out of because I just had this image of
Gary Kasparov putting the turkey in the
oven and then coming on skype to join us
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna eat his
cooking that's not happening I got a
story about Vladimir cooking by the way
but final thoughts Maurice as this
historic ninth draw in a row is in yeah
we want this match to get cooking for
sure is we have nine draws in a row a
dubious record to be sure I'm sure the
players are not proud of it they're not
happy with not making the most of their
chances and now they have put the
tension on their shoulders with just
three games to go it's a three game
classical match now three games to go to
whites for Fabi anything could happen
we're seeing it game after game after
game the first win is going to be
volcanic is that's how bad it will be if
you lose a game you're just gonna get
crushed
so they that's the feeling they have
like there's there's no comeback there's
no tomorrow
but we will be here tomorrow all turkey
day start your morning off right before
watching some football for the Americans
here watching American football or
enjoying the evening in Europe this is
the show indeed to watch as these two
great champ Sugrue great players will be
going at it to see who will finally win
the World Championship
well we're thankful to all of our
viewers and we welcome you to come
tomorrow spend a little bit of
Thanksgiving with us watching this epic
World Chess Championships thank you very
much for joining us join us tomorrow for
Thanksgiving here in the United States
and for Game 10 of the World Chess
Championship in London
[Music]